it's like you really are your only
comparison group especially as you get
older because your life is so
idiosyncratic and peculiar I mean look
you have to care what other people think
it's stupid to think otherwise because
you have to be social and you have to be
aware of what other people are doing and
all of that so this is a psychopathic
individuality but it is genuinely true
that no one has a set of opportunities
and limitations and so the comparison
just isn't real it can't be sufficiently
multi-dimensional I've met many people
who are very very rich and you can look
at their lives and they have these huge
houses and material planting and they're
shielded from many catastrophes that
would hit someone without those
resources harder but their lives are
still full of exactly the same troubles
that characterize human life in general
and so you compare yourself on one
dimension you don't see while the
person's worked 80 hours a week for 40
years and it's blown all his
relationships out of the water it's like
yes he's rich but he's also old now and
one of the best predictors of wealth is
age you know really do you want to be
young and poor or old and Rich it's like
I'd pick young and poor because you
can't by you and that's something that's
worth considering but you don't know
what burdens the people you're jealous
of so leave it be it's not helpful to
you to be envious
need motivation what are the thing with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the
with them from one of the best Jordan
Peterson and my take on his top 50 rules
of success enjoy
if you know what you want then you know
when you're failing
if you don't allow yourself to know what
you want you can keep that foggy
if you don't set out the conditions for
your success then you can avoid your
responsibility because again that's not
clear and the problem with wanting
something is that in all probability
you're going to have to work for it
you're going to have to make sacrifices
and it's certainly possible that you
want to avoid that
um
you you might be afraid to make it clear
because other people could deny it to
you too which is something I write about
a fair bit in that chapter
um the problem is and and
failing to make any of that clear
protects you right now
but it's really hard on you over the
medium to long term because if you don't
make it clear to yourself what you want
or to other people the probability that
you're just going to stumble into it is
pretty low and and you can put that off
indefinitely day after day but the
problem with that is that you age while
you're doing that and
there's a obviously a price to be paid
for that so
that chapter that's chapter three do not
hide things in the fog
I mean it's a it's a warning about
failing to pay attention
you know knowledge emerges in a very
strange way it it emerges
obviously when we learn something we
started out by not knowing it and so
what that means is that knowledge goes
through a transformation process from
being absolutely not there to being
explicit and fully detailed and one step
of that process is emotion and so for
example you might find yourself
frustrated and disappointed about the
events of the day but be unable to
exactly specify why that's extremely
common you know you go home to your
partner and you'd be in a bad mood and
you know you'll snap at them for
something and they'll say well what's up
with you and you'll say well nothing
you're just being annoying when it's
perfectly clear to both of you that
there is actually something up with you
and then that disappointment and
frustration anger and sadness let's say
or anxiety is a sign that something
isn't right but it isn't like it isn't
necessarily that you're repressing
knowledge of what's not right it's that
you just you actually don't know and the
emotion is the first step in the process
by which that knowledge emerges and you
might have to sit and think and talk to
your partner to a friend for God only
knows how long before you're actually
going to put your finger on what it is
that you're upset about and it could be
very far removed from whatever happened
to trigger you in the moment and so
that's the fog and you can keep things
in the fog just by not doing that it's
really easy it's no diff more difficult
than just sitting there doing nothing
because creating knowledge is active and
difficult the best advice that you can
really give to people who are young is
that unless you have very good reason
not to you should do what all people
have always done
and so what does that mean I I when I
see my clinical clients although I'm not
practicing anymore when I saw my
clinical clients I would evaluate their
lives across a number of Dimensions
um did were they immersed in a network
of friendships
did they have a family that could be
their family of birth but also
the family that they've produced their
own husband or wife and children
if they were of an age where that was
appropriate
did they have a career or at least a job
and was their job productive and
um match well with their abilities and
their Ambitions were they educated to
the extent that their intelligence and
curiosity might demand
were they in reasonable physical and
mental health independent of those other
areas all of those things need to be
established and
you don't want to question them so much
that you don't establish them you might
think of yourself as a rebel and someone
who's particularly unique and it's all
it's also possible that you are unique
in one or more ways but but
fundamentally speaking if you don't do
what everyone else does then the
probability that you're abdicating your
responsibility and that you will miss
out on something important is extremely
high
so I mean you know our culture virtually
every movie that's made for children now
you see this coming out of the Disney
Studios constantly always concentrates
on the special child who's got abilities
that no other child has and is being
crushed by Society into being
you know unpleasantly normal and and and
and
there is a fair bit of crushing that
goes along with being socialized because
part of being socialized is to become
like everyone else but you don't want to
underestimate the benefit of that it's
it's very very difficult to tread your
own path and you're only going to be
able to do that in a limited number of
areas
you blow apart the social routines
um you'll find yourself out there in a
domain of chaos that will overwhelm you
and that's not pleasant you do not want
that with regards to your goals
let's say you don't know what to do well
maybe you're high in openness and so
you're pulled in all sorts of directions
or maybe you're low in conscientiousness
or you're confused because you're
anxious or you haven't had any direction
you haven't had good mentoring
etc etc there's lots of reasons well I
would say
pick something right pick something a
nameable goal
and then try to implement it and what
will happen is
you'll learn a lot by trying to
implement it and one of the things you
might learn is what the a slightly
better goal might be you know because if
you try something diligently and you
succeed or you fail you're going to
learn from the the effort expanded in
the detailed implementation of the goal
is going to inform you it'll also
transform you physiologically it does
that at a very basic level neural
neurophysiological level
you will be slightly different as a
consequence of the attempt and what
that'll mean is that the next goal you
pick will be a little more suited to you
and so it's this kind of pathway right
it's like maybe the goal you should be
attaining is here but you don't know
that because you're clueless and so you
aim there well it's better than there
and it's not nothing it's not cessation
of movement and you know if you if
you're supposed to go there and you go
here but you walk diligently towards it
you're a little closer once you get to
here than you were here and it's this
oscillating self-corrective process that
leads you to the final star
and you have to be willing to engage in
erroneous experimentation to to manage
that but it is a self-correcting process
and so one of the things I always talk
to my clients about is well
well let's try something you know and
and we'll Reserve to ourselves the right
to alter our trajectory
and then I would use as a corrective
there because you might say well how do
you know when you're not just giving out
right instead of thinking maybe you need
a different goal and I would say well
you can if you're really concerned about
your proclivity for self-deception you
can enter into a contract with yourself
that you won't replace any goal you've
set with a goal that's easier
and so you can switch your goal but it
has to be a little harder so that you
check yourself against that tendency to
withdraw and avoid and be self-deceptive
and that works like a charm and if you
do that with some degree of diligence
your goals will get better and more
attainable and you'll get happier too
because you don't experience happiness
except in relationship to a goal and
that's really worth knowing you know and
that's another thing to think about too
if your life is meaningless while you're
not pursuing a valued goal I mean you
might be depressed too and sometimes
that can be like an illness you know
something that is really wrong with you
but A good rule of thumb is that if you
find new joy in life
there's a very low probability that
you're pursuing a goal that you regard
intrinsically like in the depths of your
temperament as worthwhile and that's
technically true because we do in fact
experience most of the positive emotion
let's say that's associated with with uh
with emotions like joy we experience
that in relationship to a goal
so well then you want to find a goal
that regulates your negative emotion and
that brings you a certain amount of
positive emotion and that expands your
competence as you pursue it and you will
experience that as meaningful that's
really what meaning signals meaning
signals you're doing all those things
you say well that's not real it's like
okay
don't listen to the semantic Chatterbox
so much
right there's levels of you that are far
wiser than that and you can watch what
happens to you instead of noticing what
you think also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there if
the goal of life is to live a life which
in retrospect we are glad that we lived
it's important to give ourselves
perspective
to develop that metacognizance to step
away from the Urgent to step away from
the phenomenological day-to-day
existence because the present self is a
petulant child it's lazy and it wants
the path of least resistance and that
glass of wine and that new movie on
Netflix and the couch looks really
comfortable
very rarely does it yeah well that's the
danger with impulsive happiness is that
it does have that present bound quality
and in retrospect
that can lead to a life that's not well
lived
generally that yes yes
life
definitely places philosophical demands
on you whether you want it to or not and
so it is just useful to step back I mean
that's likely why
the trade openness evolved that's the
creativity Dimension that's the
dimension that that allows people to
engage in philosophical discourse and to
think laterally and it it does allow you
to step back and look at things on a
broader scale and to generate creative
Alternatives the problem with examining
your assumptions is it's very
disquieting
you know because
you want things to act the way you
predict and desire them to act
and you work within a set of axioms and
you act them out in order to maintain
that predictability
that desirable predictability
if you mess around the more fundamental
the Axiom that you question the more
uncertainty you release
and some of that can be positive but a
plenty of it can be anxiety provoking I
mean just imagine that you're in a
relationship and
you know it's it's maybe a year into it
you haven't formalized and finalized it
but then one day you allow yourself to
ask the question is this the
relationship I want to be in well that's
a fundamental question but just imagine
now you're destabilizing your entire
future
you're destabilizing your present you're
destabilizing your past because while
engaging in the relationship you're
acting out the assumption that it's the
proper relationship but now you question
that that means the story you told
yourself about what was happening well
it happened even though it's already
happened was wrong and something else
had happened and then you have to think
through what actually happened so it's
unbelievably demanding and the more
axiomatic the Assumption the more
certainty is cast into into Troublesome
chaos now you could say yeah but the
alternative is worse
and I believe that often that's true but
but the thing about the alternative is
that you can always forestall it right
that question tomorrow you bet you bet
and it's a very powerful Temptation and
no wonder
you know do you want to dig up the body
now or do you want to wait a month it's
like well it'll be more rotten in a
month but
but it's not a month it's not now right
it's not now
and so I I understand why people don't
want to delve into things even if their
emotions indicate that they should I
mean I would see this all the time if
you're trying to settle an important
issue with your partner let's say
that can be a tremendously Troublesome
excavation process
and there's no shortage of pain but
if you sort it out then maybe things can
be better doesn't mean it's easy or or
or uh or Pleasant quite the contrary
it's like surgery it's not it's like
surgery to remove something you know
that shouldn't be there it's necessary
but man it's still surgery on that point
of understanding my inadequacies or
someone's inadequacies I really believe
um that it's really difficult to undergo
self-development if you don't have
self-awareness and I was I was really
trying to understand from your writings
how someone is to build their
self-awareness it's almost like the
unknown are known if you don't have how
do you build the thing I know a good
exercise for that
It's Like a Prayer in some sense in fact
I would say it's proper prayer if you
want to know something about yourself
sit on your bed one night and say to
yourself you got to mean this like you
got to be desperate this is no game this
it's like
my life is not everything I wanted to be
and perhaps it's not everything that I
need it to be and by need I mean my life
is so unbearable that
the suffering that's attended upon that
is make me nihilistic cynical bitter
resentful homicidal genocidal unable to
have a good relationship Pro prone to
punish people for their virtues because
of my jealousy
uh driving the proclivity to see evil
everywhere except within my own Heart
Like These are problems man
and you ask yourself you sit on the bed
and say okay man I'm ready to
learn something like what what's one
thing I'm doing wrong that I know I'm
doing wrong that I could fix that I
would fix it's like you meditate on that
you'll get an answer and it won't be one
you want but it'll be the necessary one
you know and it's often
something that will point you to small
things
so Carl Jung said people in the modern
worlds don't see God because they don't
look low enough
and so imagine you're in your messy
bedroom
you know and you're sitting on the edge
of the bed trying to have an honest
dialogue with yourself and the little
voice says
you know it's pretty disgusting in here
and you think well I'm way above Such
trivial niceties as organizing my room
it's like
well that's Pride that's arrogance
if you're above
organizing what's actually yours how in
the world are you ever going to organize
anything else and so you get on your
knees and you think
well it's time to you know
take a brush to the toilet
and maybe that's where you start
and so and that works like that works
you start making those micro
improvements like real micro
improvements real on the ground actual
micro improvements to things you know
that are wrong you'll improve
unbelievably rapidly thoughts on the
drug epidemic
well I'm not sure there is an epidemic
any more than there always has been I
know that there is now a tilt towards
drugs in in the U.S in particular like
meth and and
um Fentanyl and the other opiates now
it's quite a catastrophe
um
a lot of that is occurring among people
who don't have
meaning in their lives I would say you
might think that's a facile answer but
it's not you know like here here's the
rap Literature Like It's if you take a
Rat Lab Rat typical lab rat is you know
genetically Brad uh to be identical with
many other lab routes and he lives alone
in a cage and he he's got a pretty
miserable route life because rats are
social animals and they don't like to
live in cages by themselves and you can
get a lab rat in a cage addicted to
cocaine in no time flat and he'll he'll
like press a lever for cocaine reward
pretty much to the ex to the exclusion
of all else including sex and often
including food but if you take that same
rat and you put them in a rat family you
know in a rat social hierarchy in a rat
environment and give him something that
rat rat like to do so that he can be
satisfied it's very difficult to get him
addicted to cocaine and so I would say
the reason that people take psychomotor
stimulants and all the drugs of serious
abuse are psychomotor stimulants
regardless of what else they might be
they activate the dopaminergic system
which is the system that tracks reward
and that that is associated that's
activated when you pursue valuable goal
directed Behavior if you don't have that
if you don't have a valid goal if you
don't no real valid meaning in your life
you don't have a valid ambition then you
don't have any way of activating that
system and why the hell wouldn't you
take drugs it's like you have to have
something better to do to not addict
yourself you know so so I would say that
a huge part of the current epidemic in
in the U.S in particular is is Manifest
among broken men who have no real place
in society and providing them with money
isn't going to help that they need a
productive and meaningful existence and
which is the Paramount the Paramount
goal should be the Paramount goal of
social of social policy for example we
it isn't the alleviation of poverty
that's really the issue because people
in the west aren't poor there might be a
bit of a distribution problem but we're
not poor what we have is a
uh what would you say a
we have a problem of meaningful
engagement and that's what has to be
addressed and that's why I do the work
that I'm doing how much do people have
to kind of date around to find somebody
though because it does take a bit of
exploration to find somebody you're
compatible with so what's a reasonable
amount of exploration and like by what
age should people have figured it out
because I mean there's always the grass
looks Greener so at some point maybe you
should just settle down but what are
your thoughts on that
oh
life isn't very long
and so you don't get to evaluate that
many relationships you probably only
have a five to ten year period to do
that something like that and then
the reason you only have that amount of
time is because it gets more and more
difficult as you get older rather than
easier partly because people your age
are increasingly in relationships so I
would say get at it don't don't
overestimate the degree to which you
have to find someone versus
create the relationship you know there's
many cultures and I'm not I'm not
suggesting that this is necessarily a
desirable alternative
but there are many cultures that arrange
marriages and those arranged marriages
frequently work it's not obvious that
they work less frequently than
relationships or marriages that are
predicated on romantic attraction
which has its own pitfalls
is that no matter who you find there are
going to be full of flaws like you are
and so a lot of it is something you
create I think you want to find someone
you can trust and someone that you're
attracted to and perhaps someone who
shares the same ambitions
as you do or at least has Ambitions that
are compatible with yours and then
well then pretty much all of it after
that is what you create rather than what
you find is part of the reason that
arranged relationships or arranged
marriages work is part of it because
there's a societal pressure to not get
divorced and because it's somebody your
parents have chosen there might be an
expectation that you're supposed to
uphold of course I mean that's partly
why marriages in the west work too or
marriages and cultures where
the primary impetus for the marriage is
romantic or sexual attraction part of
the reason those marriages works is
because work is because of social
pressure
it it's very difficult to sustain a
relationship across time and you need
all sorts of social institutions
as well as conceptual schemes operating
to help ensure that that's the case
because life is so difficult you're
going to go through periods of time
where your relationship is
extraordinarily difficult but there's no
escaping that and if the pressure to
stay together wasn't there the
relationship might fragment prematurely
and then Not only would you have your
problems you'd also not have any
relationships and that's not helpful
so you go through thick and thin
together and it can be very thin the
thin times can be very thin
but
that the collective Judgment of the
human race so far has been that
long-term monogamous relationships are
the best that you can manage
and that's true cross-culturally with
there are exceptions polygamy is is
relatively common nowhere near as common
as monogamy but there are exceptions
made for polygamy but
the problem with polygamous societies is
that they tend to be more violent
especially the young men in them tend to
be more violent because they are more
Shut Out Of The Mating Game and that
makes them very frustrated oh that makes
sense so it'd be mostly yeah that makes
sense that'd make me pissed off too why
is this why is this guy over here have
seven wives he'd be better off dead yes
yes and I might be the one to help them
along with that yeah I mean that's part
of what monogamy does is stabilize
societies and that means that fewer
stable unstable societies fewer people
die and so
All Things Considered our species has
decided that that's a good trade-off how
is it the discipline and the straight
and narrow offer the best chance for a
good life and and how is it that we have
forgotten that is the case
well the reason that discipline is
necessary is because you're a massive
competing short-term interests
and so the question is then well which
short-term interest should win out and
the answer to that is well none of them
they need to be organized into a
hierarchy
that makes them functional across time
and across individuals so like a
two-year-old is very likely to act out
his or her proximal impulse but of
course a two-year-old can't survive in
the world
you have to Reagan you have to bring
your your primary instincts let's say
under the regulatory structure of a
higher order value system that allows
them to manifest themselves without
undo Mutual sacrifice across large spans
of time in the presence of large numbers
of other people so that requires a very
sophisticated ordering it's like we
already talked about the fact that a
metanarrative is necessary to unite
subcultures say so that they can operate
peacefully and harmoniously within the
same space the same thing applies within
you because you're like an you're an
internal Coalition of Warring
single-minded tribes and they have to
all be brought under the organizational
structure of long-term Collective Vision
let's say and in order to do that you
have to be disciplined and any
discipline speaking you know technically
speaking is an attempt to bring all
those competing short-term impulses
under a large a larger scale and more
inclusive framework
and so you do that and then well that's
actually what gives you freedom
being impulsive and being free aren't
the same things because if you're
impulsive you're just the slave of your
impulses right there's no freedom in
that that's that's just that's the same
Freedom so to speak literally that a
two-year-old has because a two-year-old
isn't socialized yet so it's not
it's a completely
it that doesn't function in this in this
sophisticated World it doesn't work
right everyone knows it my father gave
me an Abiding and then the other thing I
should say about him is he spent a
tremendous amount of time with me when I
was very young say before I was five or
six he taught me to read he did that
every night for months and I remember
that very vividly and instilled in me a
love of books and affluency in Reading
um he
believe that I could do
what I set my mind to
and he really believed that and to have
someone there believe that of you that's
something man and you know it was
something that I wanted to offer to my
clinical clients you know because I did
believe that
there was more to them than the
suffering person that was sitting there
and that you know with joint diligent
effort we could sift our way through the
chaff and find the wheat and that things
could be better and one of the lovely
things about practicing as a clinician
was that that was that almost inevitably
happened and sometimes really radically
and and then of course later it started
started to happen on a broader scale and
I was seeing that happen in the lives of
maybe thousands of people we're built to
walk uphill and when you reach the
Pinnacle of the Hill you want to stop
and appreciate the vision but the next
thing you want is a higher Hill in the
distance because it's the uphill climb
that it's it's from the uphill climb
that we derive our value and I mean this
technically so almost all the positive
emotion we feel especially the the the
the emotion that fills us with
enthusiasm and that's to be filled with
the spirit of God by the way because
that's what enthusiasm means that's
experienced in relationship to a goal
and so in some sense and this is part of
the religious Enterprise you want a goal
that you can never Attain
right so you can always move closer to
the goal that recedes as you move
towards it you think well that's
frustrating it's like Sisyphus pushing
the rock uphill but it's not because as
you pursue that goal you put yourself
together and your life does get better
and richer and more abundant that's why
the highest levels of virtue and goal
are in some sense Transcendent you want
them to be above everything you're doing
so you can continually move towards
something that's more Sublime and better
that's what you are you're here to live
not to not to sleep and the problem with
the vision of my Ties on the beach is
that well first of all that's an
Envision that's a vision of of
drug-induced unconsciousness second it's
only going to work for about a week
third you're going to be a laughing
stock in a month and depressed and
aimless and and goalless it's no that's
not it's it's you want a horizon of ever
expanding possibility and so it does
happen to people as they because they've
staked their soul on the attainment of
an instrumental goal and it can be a
pretty high order goal it was in your
case but then you think well I've now
I'm there now what
well the answer can't be
well I'm going to live in the lap of
luxury and never have to leave the what
do you want to be a giant infant with a
gold with a gold bottle you never have
to do anything but lay in your back and
suck it's like well you see the problem
with that as a as a as a
conceptualization it's no you want to be
like an active Warrior moving uphill
with your sword in hand and that's
that's Dynamic that's exciting and
that's why so many young men disappear
into video games it's that's all acted
out in the video game
so they have to act that out in their
own life not that I despise video games
because I don't but they're not a
substitute for life they might be good
training under some conditions for life
you go to a party your heart's beating
why the party is a monster why because
it's judging you and it's judging you
it's putting you low down the dominance
hierarchy because that's what a negative
judgment is and that interferes with
your sexual success and that means that
you're being harshly evaluated by Nature
itself right so you are confronting that
the dragon of chaos when you go into the
social situation and so what do you do
you're like this right you hunch over
and that's low dominance I'm no threat
it's like oh that's not going to get you
very far you know but that's a logical
thing to do in in the in in the face of
a tyrant so I'm no threat you know you
look at the king and you're dead I'm no
threat I'm hunched over and then what's
happening internally how what are people
thinking about me what are people
thinking about me am I looking stupid am
I looking foolish you is I'm awkward I
hate being here man I'm sweating too
much it's all internalized right it's
all self-focused the the eye isn't work
the eye isn't working what do you tell
people
stop don't stop thinking about yourself
because you can't it's like don't think
of a white elephant white elephant white
elephant white elephant you can't tell
someone to stop thinking about something
because they get caught in the loop what
you do with socially anxious people is
you say look at other people look at
them right why because if you look at
them you can tell what they're thinking
and then you you unless you're unless
you're terribly socialized and some
people are some people have no social
skills and so the reason they can't go
to a party is because they don't even
know how to introduce themselves like
they're just no one ever taught them how
to behave and so they're really good
candidates for behavior therapy because
you walk them through the process of how
you actually
manifest the procedures that are
associated with social acceptability but
most people aren't like that they have
the ability so if they're really
introverted in higher neuroticism they
can usually talk quite well to someone
one-on-one why because they look at them
well if I look at you it's another thing
to do if you're ever speaking to a group
of people never speak to the group of
people that doesn't exist you talk to
individuals and then they reflect for
you the entire group because they're all
entrained so you look at one person they
broadcast you what everyone's thinking
and you know how to talk to one person
so it's easy so as soon as you focus on
the person not you you push your
attention outward use your eye you push
your attention outward and you start
watching well then all your automatic
mechanisms kick in and you start being
awkward because if we're talking and I'm
looking here
I don't know what you're going to do
next and I'm going to put disjunctions
into the like they're like uh bad cords
in The Melody of our of our conversation
and the reason is I'm not paying
attention so that's why the eye is the
thing at the top of the pyramid it's
like the thing that enables you to win
the set of all possible dominance
herkies is the I pay attention pay
attention that's the critical issue
that's why the Egyptians worshiped Horus
that's why Horus was the thing that
rescued Osiris from the from the depths
it's the capacity to pay attention what
do you pay attention to most
what your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous it attracts your attention
it's like this isn't going quite right
I'm not looking at that wrong
that's what you look at that's what you
look at what's not going right because
that's see that's the terrible monster
that might eat you but it's also the
place you get all the information
so that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies
because they will tell you things you do
not know and that's such a great thing
because if you don't know them well
you're not very smart are you you know
there may be a time when you go
somewhere that that's the thing you need
to know and maybe your enemy will tell
you why you're such a fool you know and
a bunch of other things that aren't true
too
but even one thing that's accurate it's
like yeah thanks very much man maybe
I'll do some work on that and I won't
have to carry that forward so and then
that's part of the reason again why that
terrible Predator it's always the
terrible Predator that has the gold it's
like it's the person who delivers the
message you do not want to hear
so it's rough it's rough but it doesn't
matter life is rough responsibility
That's What Gives Life Meaning it's like
lift a load
then you can tolerate yourself right
because look at you're useless easily
hurt easily killed why should you have
any self-respect that's the story of the
Fall
pick something up and carry it make it
heavy enough so that you can think yeah
well useless as I am at least I could
move that from there to there well
what's really cool about that is that
when I talk to these crowds about this
the Man's eyes light up and that's very
like I've seen that phenomenon because
I've been talking about this
mythological material for a long time
and I can see when I'm watching crowds
people you know their eyebrows lift
their eyes light up because I put
something together for them that's what
mythological stories do so I'm not
taking responsibility for that that's
what the stories do so I say the story
and people go click click click you know
when their eyes light up but this
responsibility thing that's a whole new
order of this is that young men are so
hungry for that it is unbelievable and
one of the things I've been talking to
some of the people who've been running
for the conservative leadership in
Canada and I've been talking to them
about well the difficulties they have
communicating with young people because
conservatives what the hell are they
going to sell to young people right
because being conservative is something
that happens when you're older they can
sell responsibility aim yourself in One
Direction and I had a rule with my
clients because you know you might say
well I've gone halfway down this path
and I found out it's wrong so how do you
distinguish that from just giving up
well that's a really hard question right
it's it's a moral hazard
because it's inappropriate to continue
in a direction you now realize to be
wrong but it's also inappropriate to
give up and use that rationalization as
an excuse and how do you distinguish
especially students will not transparent
to ourselves well right exactly so that
is genuinely a moral hazard so one of
the principles that I tried to abide by
in my therapeutic discussions was you
can change course as long as the next
thing you do is equally or more
difficult
because that's a check against just
giving up
so
you want to discipline yourself so you
can get yourself organized so that you
can go in a particular direction so that
when you find the right direction you
can really go in that direction and that
does require an apprenticeship of sorts
and it might not matter in some sense
exactly what the apprenticeship is as
long as it is rigorous
right and so that sort of a bridge
between moral relativism and moral
absolutism
there's lots of games you can play
it's not that obvious a priority which
is the best game so that's kind of a
morally relative stance there's multiple
playable games
but then the absolute is yeah but you
have to play one of them you have to
learn to play one of them F become an
expert at at least one of them and then
that's not a relative
proposition and I believe that's true
that seems to me to be the case so you
want to commit to something
and then you you have when you commit to
something you require yourself to bring
all of your disparate disparate
components
moving in a single Direction United in a
single Direction so it's a unifying it's
a unifying Act
and then once having been Unified
well then you can bring that Unity to
bear on a variety of different tasks but
you have to bring it together first
so and that that makes sense
developmentally you see children start
out
as a disparate bundle of motivations and
emotions sort of Warring with one
another
and then they can integrate that into
single games that they can play with
themselves and then they integrate that
with games they start to play with other
people and all of that is integration
it's it's not subjugation it's not
repression not if it's a good game it's
integration you want to get integrated
because then you have
all the horses that are pulling your
chariot pulling in the same direction
and you're much more likely to get to
where you want to go then and also much
more likely to specify a good place to
go
so
that's another re that's something else
conservatives have to teach young people
which is well get yourself disciplined
well why
well not so you're a slave but so that
you could be a master
to use a terminology that you're not
supposed to use anymore but you know
this is in relationship to yourself
not to others
so
yeah and to begin with you have to
accept an external Master because
you just don't have the wisdom to do
that for yourself or the ability or the
opportunity often
everybody knows this you know they feel
bad when they
they decide they're going to put get
themselves in good shape and go to the
gym and lasts like three
the attempts yeah and then no one's
happy about the fact that they've quit
and they berate themselves for it and we
know that we need to go through a
disciplinary process and we need to
subjugate ourselves to a disciplinary
process that's part of the problem with
the constant harping about the you know
oppressive patriarchy
so you need a disciplinary process
so
well that's just oppression and slavery
it's like no it's not
no more than a game is
not not a good game a good game isn't
oppression and slavery you're going to
have to put some effort into your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five manner you know
if you're extroverted you want friends
if you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship if you're disagreeable you
want to win competitions if you're open
you want to engage in Creative activity
if you're high neuroticism you want
security okay so those are all sources
of potential motivation that you could
draw on that you could tailor to your
own you know your own personality but
then there are dimensions that you want
to consider your life across and so we
ask people about well you know if you
could have your life the way you wanted
it in three to five years if you were
taking care of yourself properly you
know what would you want from your
friendships what would you want from
your intimate relationship how would you
like to structure your family what do
you want for your career well how are
you going to use your time outside of
your job and how are you going to
regulate your mental physical mental and
physical health and maybe also your drug
and alcohol use because that's that's a
good place to Auger down you know
because alcoholism for example wipes out
you know five to ten percent of of
people so you want to keep that under
control and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
Associates
the so the goal once the goal is
established and then you break down the
goal into micro processes that you can
implement the microprocesses become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their uh causal association with the
goal and that tangles in your your
incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward and the way it
works is that it works better if it
produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is well you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as I can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want to you want
to specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer that has to be because you've
determined by some means that it's
worthwhile and then the next question
might be well where should you look for
worthwhile things and one would be well
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how look at what it is that
people accrue that's valuable across the
lifespan look look what so you do a
structural analysis of the
sub-components of human existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends like you don't need to have
all these things but you better have
most of them family friends career
educational goals plans for you know
time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health Etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you when I was 25
or so I probably weighed about 138
pounds I smoked like a pack of
cigarettes a day I drank
tremendous amount of alcohol I was from
Northern Alberta this rough little town
up in Northern Alberta called Fairview
and you know there were long Winters
there and my friends were heavy Drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot I
started when I was 14 and you know um
and so I was I had a lot of bad habits
let's say and uh things that were and I
wasn't in great shape physically and I
was also still intellectually obsessed
by as I am now and uh
so that would have been that would have
been an 85 but when I but I decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that I was
really going to try to get my act
together and uh
so I started doing that I you know I
first of all I I quit smoking Well that
took a long time because I eventually
had to quit drinking too in order to
quit smoking and I started working out
starting playing sports which I'd never
done I had a fine time when I was a kid
and but I needed really to get
disciplined and I had to do it because
I was working on these hard problems
that you know that I've been discussing
with all of you and I've been working on
them really you know obsessively since I
was probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when I was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like I
published 15 papers by the time I
graduated with my PhD which was by I
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any graduate student at that
time had ever published at McGill I
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time I wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible terribly difficult
thing to do because I was writing about
three hours a day doing that and I
couldn't do all that and continue with
my misbehavior you know my sort of my
what what would you say my my my
hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that I just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so you know
I had to stop that's the sacrifice I had
to stop
messing about and straight myself out
becoming more articulate is definitely I
would say
that's the primary
array of weapons
so I mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well but
the same thing replicated at the level
of the ability to communicate and to
think that's a way broader field of of
battle and opportunity
so this is one thing that isn't taught
well especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
I would say because they're more uh
skeptical of such of the educational
Enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
an agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their IQ and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to Marshal your arguments right
some
Battlefield metaphor
get everything in order
get all your information straight
you know to Marshal your forces
and so I mean that's part of the reason
that rap
artists are so popular especially among
disinfected young men black and white
alike
because they're unbelievably articulate
like they have this incredible verbal
prowess it's unbelievably attractive you
know and it's associated with genuine
artistic and Redemptive
activity often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and it's
interesting to see how many young white
guys identify with that because people
think that the purpose of memory is to
remember the past and that's not the
purpose of memory the purpose of memory
is to extract out from the past lessons
to structure the future and that that's
the purpose of personal memory and so
you're done with a memory when you've
extracted out the information that you
can use to guide yourself properly in
the future so if you have a traumatic
memory for example that's really
obsessing you if you analyze that memory
to the point where you figured out how
you put yourself at risk and you can
determine how you might avoid that in
the future then the emotion associated
with that goes away so memories has a
very pragmatic function and cultural
memory is the same thing is that we need
to extract out stories from our past
that structure our future and we need
that because
well first of all if you don't have a
purpose let's say it isn't that your
life becomes neutral in a meaningless
sense it's that your life becomes
characterized by unbearable suffering
because the Baseline condition of life
is something like unbearable suffering
and what you have to set against that is
a noble and worthwhile purpose and
hopefully hopefully your determination
of that purpose is buttressed to some
degree by the wisdom of the past because
you can't conjure something like that up
on your own and if you provide people
with nobility of purpose then they can
tolerate the suffering of existence
without becoming entirely corrupted by
it and cultures that don't do that it
isn't even so much that they die it's
that cultures that don't do that are
dead they're done they don't have a
story anymore they don't have a call to
Adventure and then well then everyone
suffers stupidly as a consequence it's a
very bad thing so Churchill made the
same observation that many of the Great
psychologists and and philosophers made
in the early part of the 20th century
it's like
bring the story forward and and
propagate it and make it the most noble
possible story and then you motivate
people to do to transcend themselves
which they need to do so yes he's
exactly right in his diagnosis there's
an entire what literature psychoanalytic
literature on the dangers of over
compassion hyper protectiveness
helicopter parenting all of that when
you have children you have to encourage
them you have to encourage them to take
risks because they have to grow up and
take their place in the world you can't
protect them too much because if you do
you destroy them that's the motif of
Hansel and Gretel right two kids lost in
the woods
they find the gingerbread house that's a
little bit too good to be true right
it's not only shelter when you need it
but it's candy what lives inside the
house that's too good to be true the
witch that devours you
right that's excess compassion
so you don't want your mother to do
everything for you that's for sure
there's a rule if you're dealing with
the elderly and like Extended Care Homes
don't do anything for your clients that
they can do themselves
because you undermine their autonomy and
so there's a certain amount of harshness
that goes along with that just as there
is if you're a good mother because you
have to separate yourself from your
child and allow them to make hurtful
mistakes right I mean it's very
difficult if you're a compassionate
person to stand back far enough to let
your children take necessary risks
but one thing I'm not getting there's a
big difference between letting people do
something for themselves and saying men
should be dangerous by dangerous that
implies I should be ready to threaten
someone to hurt somebody no you should
be capable of it
but that doesn't mean you should use it
there's nothing to you otherwise like if
you're not a formidable Force there's
not there's no morality in your
self-control if you're incapable of
violence not being violent isn't a
virtue people who teach martial arts
know this full well right if you learn a
martial art you learn to be dangerous
but simultaneously you learn to control
it both of those come together and the
combination of that capacity for danger
and the capacity for control is what
brings about the virtue otherwise you
confuse weakness with with moral virtue
I'm harmless therefore I'm good it's
like no that isn't how it works that
isn't how it works at all if you're
harmless you're just weak and if you're
weak you're not going to be good you
can't be because it takes strength to be
good it's very difficult to be good well
it's a hierarchy of virtue I would say
you know there's an old idea that God is
the sum of all that's good I don't think
some is exactly the right metaphor
it's more like imagine there are Eternal
verities truth beauty Justice love
courage
fortitude compassion
think of all those things as virtues
so virtue is what all virtues have in
common virtue is what all virtues have
in common
that's the relationship of God to the
good
God is the essence of the good
so well we put that aside for a moment
or you may think how would that manifest
itself in your life well that might be
pursuit of the good and that's the
pursuit of the good that unites all
proximal Goods
and
what is that exactly well it's something
like the
belief that it would be for the best
that all things flourish to the degree
that that's possible when I was a
clinician I thought of that as the good
in me serving the best in my clients
and I think the desire for that to
happen that's love
so that's the desire for you say well
you take a human bent broken miserable
malevolent
hurt corrupt weak pathetic contemptible
frustrating disappointing all of those
things that we can lay on ourselves
because of our inadequacies like
what's easy to dismiss that and part of
that dismissal is what drives the notion
that the planet has too many people on
it and that we're a cancer on the face
of the Earth
it's like it's not easy to love that
but what do you want you want the broken
people to rise up
out of their Brokenness
rather than despise them for it
and then you Orient yourself towards
that and try to pull that out of people
and yourself and
and
you have to have that frame
first that's what you're aiming for and
maybe that would be the opposite of hell
this is one thing I would say that
unites Sam Harris and I despite our
differences in in belief in some sense
at the level of detail Sam is very
acutely aware of the reality of
malevolence and hell now he wouldn't
frame that metaphysically or religiously
but doesn't really matter
he is doing his best to aim away from
that as hard as he possibly can I didn't
realize till the last time I talked to
him that Sam identified the religious
tradition the dogmatic religious
tradition with the totalitarianism that
produces atrocity now I think that's a
misidentification the same way the
marxists blame
inequality on capitalism inequality is
really a problem but it's not the fault
of capitalism and totalitarian atrocity
is really a problem but to identify that
reflexively with religion or even with
religious Dogma that's a mistake
Dogma maybe but even that's tricky
because what's the difference between
Dogma knowledge you know today's
knowledge is tomorrow's dogma and
drawing the line between those two is
extremely difficult you can't just
abandon everything you think even though
it's arbitrary
you need it to guide you and it can
transform into totalitarian dogma and
promote atrocity in the Servants of in
the service of it's no longer valid
maintenance but that's a very
complicated problem pick up your damn
suffering and bear it
and try to be a good person so you don't
make it worse
well that's a truth you know I read a
lot about
the terrible things that people have
done to each other you just cannot even
imagine it
so awful
so you don't want to be someone like
that now do you have a reason to be yes
you have a lot of reasons to be God
there's reasons to be resentful about
your existence everyone you know is
going to die you know you too and
there's going to be a fair bit of pain
along the way and lots of it's going to
be unfair it's like yeah no wonder
you're resentful it's like act it out
and see what happens you make everything
you're complaining about infinitely
worse
there's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is some stupid son of
a like you could figure out a way
to make it a lot worse
so you think well what do you do about
that well you accept it that's what life
is like it's suffering that's what the
religious people have always said life
is suffering yes well who wants to admit
that well just think about it well so
what do you do in the face of that
suffering
try to reduce it
start with yourself what good are you
get yourself together for Christ's sake
so that when your father dies you're not
whining away in a corner and you can
help plan the funeral and you can stand
up solidly so that people can rely on
you that's better don't be a damn victim
of course you're a victim Jesus
obviously
put yourself together
and then maybe if you put yourself
together you know how to do that you
know what's wrong with you if you'll
admit it you know there's a few things
you could like polish up a little bit
that you might even be able to manage in
your insufficient present condition and
so you might shine yourself up a little
bit and then your eyes will be a little
more open then you can shine yourself up
a little bit more and then maybe you
could bring your family together instead
of having them be the hateful spiteful
neurotic infighting bats that you're
like doomed to spend Christmas with
so then you fix yourself up a little bit
kind of humbly because you know God
you're a fixer-upper if there ever was
one and then you've got to figure out
well can you figure out how to make
peace with your Idiot Brother and
probably not because he's just as dumb
as you so how the hell are you going to
manage that and so then you've maybe you
get somewhere that way and your family's
sort of functioning and you find out
well that kind of relieved a little bit
of suffering although it reduced the
opportunities for spiteful revenge and
that's kind of a pain in the neck and so
then you get your family together a
little bit and you're a little clued in
then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult you're wiser and so then maybe
you could put a tentative finger out
beyond the family and try to change some
little thing without wrecking it it's
like our society is complex and we teach
our students that they could just fix it
it's like go fix a military helicopter
and see how far you get with that it's
like you're going to get a dude you're
like a chimp with a wrench whack oh look
it's better it's like no it's not better
things are complicated and to fix things
is really hard and you have to be like a
golden tool to fix things and you're not
so and that's the other message of the
West
it's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life
and I'm not saying it's only the message
of the West
how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it well that's hard
it takes responsibility and I think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
everything you do matters that's the
definition of a meaningful life but
everything you do matters
you're gonna have to carry that with you
or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and
then you don't have any responsibility
because who the hell cares and you can
wander through life doing whatever you
want gratifying impulsive desires for
how useful that's going to be and you're
stuck in meaninglessness but you don't
have any responsibility which one do you
want
well ask yourself which one are you
pursuing and you'll find very rapidly
that it isn't the majority of your soul
that's pursuing the whole meaning thing
because well look what you have to do to
do that you have to take on the fact
that life is suffering you have to put
yourself together in the face of that
well that's hard I stopped wasting time
that helped a lot I stopped drinking
I stopped going to bars I really didn't
spend a lot of time with my friends when
I had young kids in particular I had
friends and I I saw them you know with
some degree of regularity but where I
cut Corners was more with social life
outside my family so I spent a lot of
time with my wife and I spent a lot of
time with my kids and I spent a lot of
time on my career and so you have to
make choices and I think those were
reasonable choices I'm not displeased
with them don't abandon your friendships
but
um but you can certainly look at where
you're wasting time and just stop doing
things that you know would be a waste of
time so and I did and so I had enough
room for my marriage and I had enough
room for my kids and I had enough room
for my career and you know sort of a
multi-dimensional career and I was
always a challenge to me too to see how
efficient I could get
um and you could also
and I've really recommended this for
relatively higher income dual income
couples who are trying to pursue dual
careers kids in marriage you can
Outsource you know higher hire a
cleaning lady if you can afford it
um
buy restaurant food if you can afford it
Etc no you can Outsource get you can
have someone do your laundry then you
can concentrate on your marriage and
your kids I know that that you know is
only an Avenue available to people who
have relatively High incomes but people
who have dual incomes have relatively
High incomes and so Outsource what's
unnecessary so that you can concentrate
on what's necessary I mean I didn't do
that when I was beginning my career
because when I lived in the United
States when I was in my late 20s and
starting my family we had one income
you'd think a Harvard beginning
Professor makes a lot of money and I
suppose that's true in some absolute
sense but relatively speaking you know
we didn't have enough money to buy
magazines we we all our money went for
for housing costs and and the basic
necessities of living I had a car that
was 20 years old 25 years old I think it
was old it was bloody thing the doors
fell apart on the person I sold it to
you know like six months down the road
they knew it was a wreck at that point
but we drove that thing right into the
ground so I know that's not necessarily
possible for everyone at the beginning
of their career but if you have two
incomes you can manage it
um
I
concentrated on my marriage and making
time for it I concentrated on spending
time with my kids consciously and I
concentrated on developing my career
those were the three elements of my life
and I had some time left over for
Creative Pursuits and and and for
friends but most of it was a matter of
getting rid of
time wastes of any sort you know and I
just
push that out of my life you know day
after day until I wasn't wasting any
time
or virtually no time and you know I've
asked my undergraduates frequently how
much time they waste per day and general
estimates are like six to eight hours of
time they regard themselves as wasting
like that's a whole career right there
right so if you just stop wasting time
you can do a tremendous amount
especially if you also try to maximize
efficiency and I always found that
incredibly
motivating you know I'm motivating
game how much can I do in the least
amount of time possible that was that's
fun to try to do that as far as I'm
concerned I know you know that's maybe
it's undoubtedly a temperamental thing
but
but if you're built if you're wired that
way that's a great meta strategy become
efficient I always ask my graduate
students when they were designing
experiments they'd come with a proposal
I'd say to them you know is there any
way you could do this ten times faster
what would you have to cut what would
you have to change to do this 10 times
faster
and you can learn to do that I also
learned to
Force the task to fit the time you know
there's this dictum work expands to fill
the time allowed for its completion work
expands to fill the time allowed for its
completion well there's a corollary to
that which is
work
becomes more efficient in proportion to
the restrictions of time placed upon it
so if you say well this could take me
two weeks but I'm going to do the best
job I could in one day you'd be amazed
you can get 90 percent of the way or 95
percent of the way or sometimes even
farther in that day
so that's another way of becoming
efficient you know if you only have 10
minutes to do something that should
maybe take you two hours maybe you can
figure out how to do it in 10 minutes
you can get dreadfully efficient
so
that's very much worthwhile in my
estimation if you want to do a lot of
things what what else are you going to
do
you know rather than become efficient if
you want to do many things you don't
have much choice but it I found it
extremely entertaining to try to do that
and when I was healthy
I could do a tremendous amount in a very
short period of time I'm very frustrated
that that's not so much the case now
although perhaps it's coming back to
some degree if I've got a friend in my
life or a you know partner that I want
to encourage to come out of that place
of Despair into a better place how do I
effectively do that without overpowering
them or stifling them or making them
feel inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love well
example is good
but then I would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person you don't not only do
you not no you actually don't want that
responsibility for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose Victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice well they pay the
price for that and you can skip away
merrily and say well I should have spoke
more carefully it's like you don't mess
about with people's Destiny you do not
know where they're headed now having
said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know like how are you
feeling
I'm not doing so good today well you
know what's up what's going on
and you can't think well I'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see what it is that you want to
know I see this when people ask me
questions after my lectures you know now
now and then or during a q a now and
then people get up and they'll ask a
real question it's part of the ongoing
dialogue something struck them they
stand up there's something they really
want to know so honest question and that
goes real well but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so I get this from
Christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is Corner me
into admitting that I should accept
Jesus Christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say uh
um denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so your questions like your
statements your questions should be
honest and if you ask people questions
and you really listen they will untangle
themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know like
if I meet people on the street you know
I ask them their name they're all
usually flustered when they come up to
me they don't really want to interrupt
me and then they're flustered and the
first thing I do is shake their hand and
ask them their name and I listen you
know not that good at remembering names
but I listen to it and and they know how
to say their name and so it kind of
settles them down and then it sort of
marks them out as a person against the
background eh and then if I pay
attention to them and listen they will
tell me something in like 10 seconds
that I need to know
because they are they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you would decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is I don't know where
you're headed I don't know what's wrong
with you this is a hard problem man it's
like what's your problem
I don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now I wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if I could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and I wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way what is it that I would
have to say or do that would in
principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well I think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then I will say what words
should I use
and they'll say well if you loved me
you'd know and I would say no I'm stupid
and ignorant and I don't know what the
right words are to satisfy you so why
don't you give me a hand with that and
I'll utter them inelegantly and
awkwardly in a good faith demonstration
of my commitment to peace and that won't
be so good because maybe it would have
been better if I came up with it myself
but maybe next time I can do slightly
better
and that works it it requires the person
who's after you to think through
the question even of whether there's
anything that could be said or done that
would satisfy them and if the answer to
that is no well probably the
relationship is over but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it you know stupidly
and badly
so listening man
Jimmy Carr I talked to Jimmy Carr two
weeks ago the Irish comedian yeah it was
real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of
of the entertainment forms and I thought
well what do you mean by that because
you just talk it's a monologue right now
I do monologues but I pay attention to
the audience right I'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching the reactions and listening to
the audience as a whole so even though
it's a lecture let's say or a talk
I'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well Carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're Corpus of potentially funny
jokes and then they do 200 shows in
front of small audiences and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening you collect all
the jokes that people laugh out if you
do that 200 times you have nothing but
hilarious material but you listened and
then you can go out on the road and that
was very interesting to me because humor
is a mysterious
phenomenon experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and Elevate ourselves at the
same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them life has proximal
meanings right there's the meaning that
you experience when you're engaged in a
piece of art or when you're reading or
when you're engrossed in a movie or in a
conversation there's the meaning that
emerges
within your relationships with people
that you cherish or are enthusiastic
with
there's meanings of security and
predictability
there's meanings of Duty and
responsibility and active engagement
with your job and your career
there's meanings of aesthetic pleasure
now
all of those have their value
and each of them has their place and you
know maybe there's a hierarchy of value
there as well so that some of those
meanings are deeper than others
and then you might say well what
characterized the deepest of all
meanings and it would be something like
relationship with the Transcendent and
that would establish a relationship
between you and
what's always been conceptualized is God
which is generally supposed to be
something ineffable right it's not
definable but you might think about it
as the central animating
Spirit of the age or the value around
which all other values are organized or
the wisdom of the ages or the creative
spirit that possesses you when you're
inspired or
what grips you with enthusiasm at a
sports event or at a musical event all
of those things and we need a
relationship with that and we find our
deepest meaning in that relationship and
if we don't find it
I think if we don't find it in something
that's explicitly
religious then we tend to magnify
something of lesser value say something
political into that to fill the void
so yes life has proximal meanings
without god without eternity but
at the ultimate level something's
lacking
and it's the desire to fulfill that lack
that and maybe the lock itself that's
part and parcel of the religious
instinct
so
you can kill God
but you can't
that doesn't rectify the hunger for God
and then that hunger seeks out
Replacements that's how it looks to me
so
and then you know you you might also say
well does that mean you have to believe
in God and uh
I don't think of the proper answer to
that is that
you need to agree with a propositional
statement does God exist yes
no like does this is this table there
yes
it's not that kind of relationship it's
characterized in the Old Testament as a
struggle so Israel means those who
struggle with God
and
you have to participate in that struggle
and you can do that weirdly enough as a
Believer as a non-believer
maybe sometimes more intensely as a
non-believer
the issue might be more Paramount than
the issue of virtue and and the issue of
the ultimate orientation there's so many
rules that are great but what do you
think is probably if if somebody was to
read those books and there's one rule
that you like this rule out of the 24
I've given you over these past few years
I you can absolutely not get this one
wrong which rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop saying things that you
know are lies and that will change your
life
if you do that and it's crazy
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
and you think well I'm just lying to
other people no you're not you can't
just lie to other people because what
you say becomes you especially if you
practice it because we build ourselves
out of words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like don't don't say things you know to
be false that's a that's a good start
man and it aligns yourself with the
truth and that like how can that be a
bad idea imagine that what is true
reflects reality which is sort of the
definition of true how can
failing to align yourself with reality
work how is that possibly going to work
well you say well I can you know if I
lie I get away with something it's like
no you don't you know I I tell you I
swear this is true
in all of my clinical practice
I have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see what your lies caused or too
blind or too self-deceptive you just
don't see it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
God fundamentally that's a very old idea
and it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
I got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's going to snap back and hit you in
the face and that's that's life man you
warp the structure of reality you think
you are someone who can warp the
structure of reality with your words and
get away with it really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not God your perceptual
structures are determined by the goals
that you have at hand I mean some of
that's that's not completely true
because your perceptual systems also
have limitations right there's things
you can't see or hear even if you need
to so there are limitations built in but
within that set of limitations you're
still trying to tune your perceptions to
your motivated goals and that's also
very useful to think about when you're
trying to understand artificial
intelligence because for human beings
without goals there's no perception
because there's no filtering mechanism
that you can use to determine the level
of resolution at which you perceive
anyway so there's the there's a thing
made of smaller things which are made
out of smaller things and it's so it's
kind of my iconic representation of the
complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and I think if you
just look at it you can detect it's like
a Necker Cube you know those cubes that
that are line drawings that you can see
the front of and then it'll flip to the
back have you seen those so this is kind
of Necker Cube like or at least it is
for me in that when I look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes I focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes I can see these other lines
and then sometimes I'll focus on that
square and sometimes I can see the
little dots there maybe one dot and my
perceptions are going like this trying
to fit a pattern to it and I you can
kind of detect that when you're watching
it and so I would say well you have the
options of perceiving this in its full
complexity or you can simplify it
essentially there's lots of ways you can
simplify it but some of them are laid
out there so you take the comp complex
thing you make a low resolution
representation of it so that's it's
rough that's the rough area that all
those dots occupy that's the rough area
broken down to its four most fundamental
quadrants that might be how you would
look at it if if this was a map of an
orchard and you were trying to walk from
south to North that would be a useful
representation this combines this and
this that's the
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then I think what happens
is we have the thing in itself and then
we simplify it with a perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when I throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do I
and I'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel because the novel
comes alive in your imagination in your
own idiosyncratic way and it wouldn't if
you didn't understand the references of
the novel right the novelist has to
assume that your basic perceptual
structures and your intuitions and your
instincts are basically the same as his
or hers because otherwise they have to
assume that because otherwise they would
be lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic often for
example if you start reading Victorian
novels you may find that it takes a
while to get into them because the
presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations you have to make a
decision in your life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in this sand and
saying here is where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being as good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and maybe that's the
most effective means of having existence
open its heart to you so for example you
know if you love other people you want
the best for them you want the best and
you deserve the best in them if you love
them and you trust them courageously so
you open yourself up to them
I don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take I think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage and
and so that's how that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities then you can imagine
I have this Cottage
in Northern Ontario and
we're fortunate
it's dark there and so you can go down
to the dock at night and in the clear
sky you can see the vast array of the
infinite heavens arrayed above you you
know and it's something that people who
live in cities really don't get to
experience anymore they don't experience
the sunset which we also go out on our
boat and watch pretty much every day
and that puts you in in touch with what
inspires awe
now when that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's it's a deep
biological experience it's in it's
embedded in the prey response to a
predator in part you know because if you
if you feel awe sometimes you can feel
that with music a lot of people are high
in openness to experience will feel that
quite frequently under the effect of
aesthetic experiences interestingly
enough their hair stands on in that's
pilo erection that's what a cat does
when it's frightened by a dog like the
little boy at the beginning of the story
you know the cat puffs up to look big to
be like medic hat so that it can contend
with it can contend with dogs or at
least it can look like it might and so
when when it sees a dog the sight of the
dog calls the best fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
you know
it calls to you
right Dr Dawkins sent me a paper last
week in preparation for a discussion
that we're going to have tomorrow and it
was very interesting paper and I think I
read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning animal has to be a
microcosm a model of the environment
within within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant and even
your encounter with mortality you're
encounter with finitude and limitation
all of that in relationship to the
infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the Divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity it's
time we woke up and realized it what's
the most effective way of overcoming
self-deception the problem of
self-deception is extremely thorny and
it's Tangled Up with the issue of
ignorance as well right how do you know
when you just don't know something and
how do you know when you're being
willfully blind and how do you know when
you're outright lying all of those
things are especially to yourself all of
those things are very complicated
so to some degree the answer is
well you have to develop a philosophy of
life that's detailed
that contains within it
an assessment of your thoughts about the
relationship between truth and deceit
so for example
do you believe that it's okay to lie is
it okay to deceive other people to get
what you want are there occasions when
it's okay to deceive other people if
that helps them get what they want so
that would be and
an instance for example of what people
perhaps call White Lies right lies that
are designed to be of benefit are they
appropriate
do you feel that it's okay to deceive
yourself or or other people
in the pursuit of things that you
believe are valuable
and none of those are trivial questions
and
and they can't be
answered with trivial answers so to some
degree you need
a moral philosophy that privileges the
truth above all else if you wish to
cease engaging in self-deception
and then you might ask well how would
you develop such a philosophy and some
of that might be well reading about
moral philosophy
Reading literature because it often
deals with questions of Good and Evil
and deception
thinking about it writing about it
reading about it well I said that
um
and and also contemplating how Central
issue this is for your life how
important is this and and why is it
important if it's important have you
lied and got into trouble do you believe
that you can lie and get away with it if
you don't believe that you can get away
with it you still engage in it if so why
all right so let's leave the complexity
behind though but but that's a necessary
part of the answer
how do you stop deceiving yourself
assuming that you want to stop doing so
well I don't believe that you can tell
unerringly when you're telling the truth
I think that some of the time when you
lie outright you know
and so what I would recommend and have
recommended in my writings in my books
especially in
12 rules for life the first of my last
two books
said tell the truth or at least don't
lie and I added that codicil to the
phrase tell the truth because it became
evident to me when I was writing that
you know I don't know the truth
certainly not in its fullness and so I
can't say to someone tell the truth but
I can say
if you believe that the truth is
valuable and if you believe that living
your life according to the dictates of
the truth is for the best for you and
and everyone else let's say
then you could at least stop lying
and then
I would say
that as you
pay attention to what you say
so that you're
attending to your
deceptive statements and trying to stop
making them some of them maybe you know
outright they're not true some of them
make you feel uneasy and weak that would
be a less uh evident criteria falsehood
but still a reasonable one
um you stop doing that and then
your eye for such things are here ear
for such things or your embodied
capacity to evaluate such things
developed just as everything develops
with practice and your intent which is
to
maintain truth in your speech become
sharper and more focused across time and
perhaps you get
as you eliminate the obvious untruths
you get better and better at detecting
the more subtle untruths and
better at better and better and better
at avoiding being entangled with those
as well
so the first
issue I guess is the decision that
it's best
to live in truth
and then you have to decide how far
you're willing to take that if that
becomes an absolute for example or if
it's a
you know an important guideline but
you know perhaps to be superseded by
other things
you have to sort that out for yourself
once having established that then I
believe that you
decide and practice
not lying
and then
possibly if you're fortunate
if the world smiles on you
you'll
engage in less self-deception
I guess the last thing I would add to
that is that there's another form of
self-deception that I wrote about in my
the second of my last two books so the
last one Beyond order there's a chapter
in there called don't hide things in the
fog that really deals with
self-deception too so you might say well
there's one form of self-deception that
occurs when you say something that you
know not to be true and pretend even to
yourself that it's true or even act as
if it's true
or base other statements or actions on
it as if it's true
but there's a more subtle form of
self-deception which I think is more
pervasive which is
the unwillingness to look at or the
willingness to turn away from evidence
that you know would
undermine something that you want to
believe
or make things inconvenient for you
you know I think I got cliched example
is
maybe someone runs a company and they
have a Chief Financial Officer and they
know that person is not exactly straight
but it's convenient not to look at the
books so
maybe when they're around that person
they feel guilty and
and uncomfortable
and that's a sign that you know
something's wrought in the state of
Denmark so to speak but then the
self-deceptive ACT is to not look where
you know you should look
and
you know that's the sort of thing that
people refer to when they talk about the
elephant under the carpet or the
skeleton in the closet
and sometimes to mix metaphors terribly
it's better to let sleeping dogs lie but
often
you know if you have this sense that
there's something more to the story
it's painful and difficult to delve into
it but to not do so which is the easy
route is a form of
of self-deception a very common
self-deception and
I don't think my experience as a
clinician
and my personal experience as well is
that
when you have a sense that something's
up
and you fail to act
you almost inevitably pay a much higher
price for it at some point deferred into
the future
so you have to think that through for
yourself and ask yourself if you believe
that's true and if it is true unless you
want more trouble in the future then
perhaps you investigate when
your moral unease let's say
makes alerts you to the fact that
there's something to investigate
wherever I go in the world people come
up to me and they're usually
I wouldn't say they're happy to see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped
desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say I've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over in some
ways you might think well how could
anything better possibly happen to you
than to have people come up to you all
over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like they're old
friends so quickly but at the same time
it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their Triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so I wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable at the end of God's
creation describing how order emerges
from chaos or being from potential
there's this strange line which is
probably the most important line that's
ever been written
in our culture at the basis of our
culture and that is that men and women
are made in the image of God and what
does that mean well if God is that which
confronts potential with truth and
courage and makes what's good out of
potential that seems to indicate that we
have the same faculty like on a smaller
scale we're not omniscient but we're not
bloody well nothing our conscious is
integrity tied into the structure of
being in some manner we don't understand
and it certainly is the case that we
take what isn't and turn it is into what
is that's something man that's that's
quite the trick we've been able to
manage and so we're made in that image
and so what are we supposed to do well
that's what we're supposed to do we're
supposed to type our letters and make
our phrases and construct our sentences
and build our paragraphs and put our
chapters together and make our books and
communicate to people and straighten out
the damn culture and constrain the
malevolence and ignorance that besides
each of us and push nature back and
extend ourselves out into the unknown
and confront the potential that's there
in the illimitable quantities and make
the world better than it could be
otherwise to Move It Away From Hell
which and it can certainly become that
and toward heaven to the degree that we
can manage that and that is a good
enough goal that's the thing you need
something you know because your life is
tough It's hard you need something that
you know you need something to get out
of bed for and fight for and that's
something right to fight let's say
against hell and for heaven that's
something to fight for you want to be
convinced about this like read a little
bit about hell read the gulag
archipelago or read ordinary men or read
the rape of Nan King or read about what
happened in Nazi Germany during
Auschwitz and all the catastrophes of
the 20th century and see if you believe
in hell and to see if you think well
maybe not not having that happen anymore
would be a good idea and then think
about maybe that's something you could
contribute to then it wouldn't have to
happen anymore
and that would be a good thing and God
only knows what great things we could
manage under such conditions we're
becoming incredibly technologically
powerful what would it be like if we
became equally wise well that would
really be something God only knows what
we could manage in the next 20 years or
the next hundred years you know we're
running at 40 percent most of us you
know because we're half in and half out
and it's not surprising because life is
difficult it's like well what if you
were 90 in or 95 in or or all in because
you're all in anyways right it's a it's
a life and death game no one gets out of
this everyone dies you might as well
commit yourself and you might as well
commit yourself to the highest good that
you can attain because why not it'll
imbue your life with meaning it's hard
the responsibilities there but all the
meanings in the responsibility and
that'll make your life better it'll make
your family's life better and it should
make your culture better
maybe make the world better it's like
that'll justify your damn miserable
existence at three o'clock in the
morning when you're wondering what the
hell you're doing here and that's a good
thing because there's going to be days
when you're aching and tired and sore
and there's people in your family that
are sick and you're cynical and bitter
and you need a reason to get up and you
think yeah well a little more heaven and
a little less hell maybe I can pull that
off today and tomorrow and next week and
that's worth struggling forward for
so that's how it looks to me my rule too
is treat yourself as if you're someone
responsible for helping and it's sort of
predicated on the idea that regardless
of your inadequacies and your
malevolence which you know I'm sure you
have many inadequacies and no shortage
of malevolence just like everyone else
regardless of that you have a moral
obligation so that would be a
responsibility to assume that despite
all evidence that there's actually
something of intrinsic worth about you
and that as a consequence your duty
bound to treat yourself like that is
true
and then it turns out that if you do
that
well then your life gets better
and and I don't mean happier exactly
although I would say it gets happier I
mean it gets richer and more meaningful
and deeper and and more worthwhile and
and you become more educated and you
become wiser and and and you treat
yourself with more respect and you're a
better model for other people and you're
a better father or a better sister or a
better mother whatever it happens to be
it's and you're less ridden by that
guilt that's that gnaws at you and shame
that's there otherwise saying you're not
what you could be you're not what you
could be and that's a hell of a voice to
get rid of and it's certainly not one
that's easy to ignore so that's a pretty
good
that that idea that there's something
Divine let's say that resides within you
of ultimate worth
um
even as a philosophical statement or a
psychological statement rather than a
metaphysical statement it seems to be a
precondition for establishing properly
harmonious relationships with yourself
and that's that's man that's worth
thinking about a lot you know that you
have to because you think you couldn't
think that in some sense you just own
yourself you know because people do kind
of make that claim especially when
they're trying to justify for example
their right to Suicide that you know
it's it's your life it's your body your
yours to do what you will with and if
that was true well then it would seem to
me that life would be a lot more
straightforward because you would just
tell yourself things that you would
instantly obey and believe so first of
all you'd tell yourself all the things
that you were going to do and then you
just run off and do them which you don't
obviously because it's much more
difficult at that and then you'd also
say well enough of the guilt and the
shame and the negative emotion and the
disillusionment and the vengefulness and
all those things that make life hard
especially the self-recrimination it's
like what the hell do we need that for
and if we're our masters of Our Own
Destiny and owners of our own fate then
why can't we just command to ourselves
that that be dispensed with and like
that doesn't work I've never seen
anybody able to do that so I mean you
can fool yourself for very brief periods
of time into thinking that that might
work but
but it doesn't work and and that's
strange and this is one of the reasons I
love the psychoanalysts say because they
were really the people apart from the
religious types who figured out that
whatever you are
you're not a unitary Spirit that's under
your own dominion you know you're
something like a loose Unity of a
multiplicity of spirits many of which
are doing their own thing which you're
striving to bring into some form of
unity but even that Unity isn't
something that's under your control in
any real sense it's it's a Unity that
has its own nature that you have to
exist in relationship to and I would
also say that that's one of the things
that keeps people people's feet firmly
on the ground because otherwise you it's
easy to become egotistical and
narcissistic you know if you if you
think that you're the center of your own
being you know in some fundamental sense
then you're only what you're only
beholden to yourself you're sort of a
self-created creature perhaps you could
think about it that way but it doesn't
work like that it's like the ideal that
constitutes the unity that you might
become then sort of manifests itself is
something that you could strive toward
but aren't and it it also serves as a
judge it's the thing that keeps you up
at night saying you know there's some
things you're just not attending to and
you should get at it because life is
short and there's no shortage of trouble
that you might end up in and a wise
person would attend to the dictates of
his conscience and and lay out his
actions in the world according to what
he knows to be true and correct and
that is how people think and it isn't
obvious that we why we think that way
that this is part of the reason that it
seems to me so obvious that we have a
religious Instinct because I can't think
of what else you would possibly call
that other than a religious Instinct the
notion that our morality is linked to
our desire to survive is I'm perfectly
fine with that
the devil's in the details to some
degree
I mean one of the
fields of endeavor that I've been
particularly struck by is uh
the work of people like Franz DeWall
and friends the wall has written a
series and also Jacques penk said hey
I'll tell you something cool about rats
some of you I'd like to do that
some of you have probably heard this
before but this affective neuroscientist
named Jacques penkseb he studied rats
for a long time and he's very
sophisticated researcher and I think he
was one of the greatest neuroscientists
who lived in the last 50 years sorry I
don't think there's really any question
of that he might have been one of the
top three
might have been
he'd be in the top three be a tight race
up at the top three
he did this great experiment was so
smart
so
juvenile routes like to play
and they like to wrestle they like to
engage in rough and tumble play and you
might say well how do you know a rat
likes to do something it's like are you
anthropomorphizing and the first thing I
would say to that is you should
anthropomorphize unless there's evidence
to the contrary because we share a
biological platform with rats and
they're a lot like us and a rat is a lot
more like you than your stupid model of
a human being is like a human being
so you try building a rat
it's hard
so anyways you can tell rats want to
play because if you put them in a little
Arena where they can Rough and Tumble
play and wrestle and then you bring them
there the next time and you make them
work to open the door to play they'll
work and so that's how we know you like
something you'll work for it you know so
you can apply that to rats and they'll
work hard for it and rats deprived of
play their prefrontal cortexes don't
mature and they they're kind of
hyperactive which might tell us
something about boys in school but we
won't go into that
if you take a rat
of the same age as another rat and you
put them in a play area
but the other rat has a 10 percent
weight advantage
the big rat will pin the little rat and
they actually pin each other pretty much
like dogs do when they're wrestling
while they don't pin quite as much but
humans certainly do it and pin means
dominate dominance or that's one
interpretation
you only make that interpretation if you
think that the hierarchies that rats
live in are dominance hierarchies
predicated on the expression of power
and we all kind of think that because we
use the term dominance hierarchy but you
know that's a political term as well as
a scientific term and it's predicated on
the notion that the fundamental basis of
hierarchical structure among mammals and
other complex organisms is power and
that's wrong
it's not just wrong it's it's
corrosively wrong it's misleadingly
wrong it's like it's seriously and not
acceptably wrong anyways you pair the
rats once and you think hey big rat wins
over little rat establishes dominance
That's the basis of the relationship
but the thing about rats is like people
they don't just play once because they
live in social groups that are
reciprocal they play repeatedly and
Banks up being a very smart researcher
realized this so he paired rats
to play the same rats over multiple
occasions
and the first thing he observed was the
second time the rats got together the
little rat had to invite the big rat to
play
you know when rats do the same sort of
thing that dogs do when they want to
play and and that that play behavior is
so cross-species common that all of you
know when your dog wants to play you
know you can you can take your dog and
whack him like that if you do it right
and he goes and tries to bite you but
not really right he plays in his Tails
wagging and and when dogs are playing it
kind of looks like dominance Behavior
like it does among boys because boys
really like to rough and humble play by
the way although girls like it too but
not as much
you can distinguish the play behavior
from aggression and if you can't that
means you never had any friends I mean
no I mean that that's that I mean that
that's what it means it means that's
what it means because part of being able
to have friends is be to be able to
identify aggression versus play and and
part of playing is to pretend to be
aggressive quite aggressively but still
be playing right there's a tremendous
social skill in that anyways
the little rat has to ask the big rat to
play which I imagine is somewhat you
know humiliating for the little rat but
he's the little rat so tough luck for
him and the big rat contained to play
and then they play and then you can
observe how they play over repeated
boats
if the big rat doesn't let the little
rat win at least 30 percent of the time
even though he could win 100 of the time
the little rat will no longer invite him
to play and you think
yeah it's like no not yeah
like the emergence of morality in rats
through play that's a big Discovery man
that's a big Discovery and that's
there's that reciprocity eh that that
exists within the rat hierarchy and
stable hierarchies in complex mammals
are not predicated on power
so friends the wall has shown quite
clearly that you know that so chimps
have a pretty rough hierarchy and it's
pretty male dominated now barnables are
quite different we won't talk about them
because it's not germane to this
particular point but you might think you
know
the biggest chimpanzee with the biggest
teeth
he's the Tyrant he's the winner
and that happens sometimes there are
tyrannical chimpanzee societies but what
dewal has shown quite clearly is that
I don't care how big and tough you are
if you don't play fair
two guys 90 your size can get together
one day when you're not feeling so well
and tear you into bits
and that's exactly what happens Among
The Chimps
so tyranny you know that can be a route
to dominance it can even be a route to
sexual access because it is the case
among chimpanzees that males who are
higher in the power hierarchy are more
likely to farther Offspring not because
the female chimps choose them because
female chimps aren't choosy unlike human
females it's a profound difference
between the two species but because the
big that more uh superordinate male
chimps chase the soup subordinates away
so but the wall is shown quite clearly
that
the males who managed to occupy
positions of authority
and competence longest in chimpanzee
hierarchies are intensely reciprocal
with the other males more so than the
other chimps in the hierarchy they do a
lot of mutual grooming and are
preferentially attentive to the females
and their infants
and so even among chimps and chimps can
be damn brutal right Jane Goodall
discovered I think it was 1975 another
landmark in in late 20th century
scientists at science that
and this was a real blow to to the
social
constructionist utopians
juvenile chimps Patrol the borders of
their territory and if they come across
chimps from other troops and outnumber
them they will tear them into bits and
chimps are unbelievably strong and it's
unbelievably brutal and so good all
basically discovered that chimps have
the human equip or the the equivalent of
human tribal Warfare
and that's quite frightening if you're
sensible because you know you might be
the kind of optimist who thinks that
human conflict is caused by capitalism
or some bloody Daft notion like that and
that wouldn't that be lovely because
then it would be you could just get rid
of it by getting rid of capitalism which
you wouldn't be able to do anyways but
you know what I mean it's but if it's
I mean we split from chimps about seven
million years ago and
if the problem of Intergroup aggression
is that deep
it's a terrible problem this is another
thing you can do in your own household
this is so useful man if you get good at
doing this your life will get so much
better you can't believe it is watch the
people around you
and whenever they do anything that you
would like to see repeated on a regular
basis
tell them exactly what they did in
detail with you know be positive about
it obviously and and just indicate that
you noticed and because I saw this when
I was grading student essays you know
and so I taught this seminar for a long
time and I was trying to teach kids how
to write they were in their fourth year
of University in the honors psych
program you'd think they'd bloody well
already know how to write but they
didn't and so
I'd have them write a four-page essay on
a given topic and then they had to
rewrite that to a six page essay and
then they had to rewrite that to an age
eight page essay and the first essay I
graded I was only five percent of their
grade and I told them I'm going to cut
you into ribbons but it doesn't matter
because it's you know five percent of
your grade and so they could tolerate
that and generally by the third essay
they had written the best thing they'd
ever written in their life and they
learned so fast it was unbelievable but
one of the things I noticed was that
they did a little testing with the first
essay they'd hand in something it was
just like
God formulaic boring they weren't in it
at all you know there was nothing of the
person in there there was no thought
there was just the kind of cycle Babble
that they'd learned especially if they
were in faculties of education and and
it was dry and dull and and everything
about it was wrong and so those are hard
to Great rights like what's wrong with
my essay well the words aren't right the
phrases they're not so good they're not
organized well into sentences the
sentences aren't sequenced well in the
paragraphs the Peregrine's paragraphs
don't make a coherent argument and the
entire thing is empty but other than
that no problem it was often easier just
to rewrite those essays than to grade
them no so in any case though one of the
things I did learn was that even in an
essay like that there is usually like
one sentence or two sentences buried on
like page three that was an actual
thought
and reasonably clearly stated and
somewhat gripping you know it was like
the person popped out from all the
background rubbish and said
well what about what about this hey and
if you saw that and checked it and said
hey you hit the mark right there the
next essay would be like two-thirds that
and that was really fun to see and then
maybe by the third essay maybe it was
all like that and then they were really
thrilled it's like wow I wrote this you
know and sort of the culmination well it
was a fourth year seminar it was the
culmination of their their career as a
psychology undergraduate so that was
great fun but you can do that in your
own household if if if
if the envious part of you isn't jealous
of the revelation of the goodness of the
person for me as a clinical psychologist
I
in some ways from the opposite
perspective of most maybe even most
psychologists like it's never been a
mystery to me why people are depressed
it's never been a mystery to me why
people are anxious and unsettled it
seems obvious why they're concerned and
hurt and anxious and unsettled I think
the mystery is
how it is that we can conduct ourselves
so that that can remain under control I
mean people deal with very heavy burdens
in their life you know you you don't
have to talk to someone for very long
someone you might might be thinking is
doing quite well in the world and and
sometimes people are
but you don't have to scratch very deep
beneath the surface before you find out
that they have a family member who has a
serious illness or someone who's
suffering through a economic crisis of
one form or another or or who there's
some source of genuine tragedy yeah
one degree removed from them if it's
even removed and most people even as
individuals have at least one serious
problem that they're dealing with and so
it's no mystery that people find it
difficult to orient themselves in the
world and the Mystery is well what can
you do about it and
we do know what you can do about it
and you know Jonathan height wrote a
book recently
um
uh
oh no I'm afraid that it's uh the name
of the book is escape me it's about the
college situation and and the snowflake
culture and um
one of the things that he pointed out
along with Logan off who's his co-author
was that
if you're a psychotherapist
of any sort particularly a behavior
therapist
what you help people do is to identify
their problems that's the first thing is
to confront what's there the reality of
what's there and as bluntly as possible
and so you often end up as a
psychotherapist talking to people about
their array of problems as it's as if
they're putting their cards on the table
and and you sort out their problems it's
like and no they often decide that many
of the things that are bothering them
are not really that important they can
wait but that there are crucial life
challenges that present themselves to
them and they're not just psychological
problems although sometimes they are
they're they're problems in life right
existential problems and then what you
do is you help people break them down
into manageable units let's say
strategically and confront them
voluntarily
you know and there's an echo of that
idea there's an echo of that in in
Christian thinking and the echo for that
is to pick up your cross voluntarily
which is that you have a you have a an
unavoidable mortal burden to bear in
life there's no escape from it
except to directly confronted and to
take it on voluntarily and what's so
fascinating about that two things one is
that psychotherapists of every stripe
understand that this is one of the
primary reasons that Psychotherapy works
there's no dispute about that among all
the different psychotherapeutic schools
is that the confrontation of
existential problems voluntary
confrontation is Curative and that's
really something
and so and and and and and and the
Practical aspect of that is quite
straightforward it it it it also
indicates practical and philosophical it
also indicates to you that
there's far more to you than you think
because it turns out that you have
substantial problems genuine deep
problems of malevolence and suffering
but that if you
decide that you will take that on as
your responsibility
that you can put yourself together
psychologically just the courage and you
can actually solve the problems and and
that seems to be true it's it's it's
it's not a naive wish it seems to be
well within our capacity and I mean
that's part of the message I would say
of 12 rules for life is that dark as
things are
there is more light in you than you know
what to do with and there's more light
in you than you can possibly manifest
and and the way to find that out is to
to challenge yourself against these
massive problems and to find out that
you're the one
that can deal with them I don't know how
many of you have read dostoevsky's crime
and punishment but I would highly
recommend that in crime and punishment
the protagonist commits the perfect
murder and he has his reasons for it and
many reasons because Dostoevsky didn't
mess around when he wanted to give
someone reasons he gave them reasons and
he was called nikov that main character
had reasons for murder and then he
commits his murder and he gets away with
it
but things don't go well for skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and riskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you you need that instinct for
meaning too so and we should get this
real straight why do you need it well
you need it because life is really
really difficult right I mean people
have a rough time of it there's plenty
of suffering in life and everyone is
going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long and and really talk to them
and get beneath the surface until you
find you know there's a tragedy or two
or three or ten lurking not very far
beneath the surface someone in the
family is very ill there's a childhood
history of extreme pathology alcoholism
somewhere in the family maybe a touch of
insanity someone has cancer you know
someone someone older relative is dying
there's financial trouble there's
economic trouble there's marital trouble
it's like life is trouble and now you
know that doesn't mean it's all trouble
but man it's trouble and sometimes it's
it's a lot of trouble and sometimes it's
so much trouble that you can you can
barely stand it and and you see that
because people you know people get
depressed and they commit suicide and
the reason they do that is because they
think not being is better than being and
that's quite the decision you know so
and and it's not that uncommon among
people who are depressed and so it's
it's a it's a very it's a very important
thing to consider and it and it isn't
just a matter of depression and suicide
that's bad enough but you know if you're
unhappy because your suffering has
pushed you past the point of your
ability to cope then there's all sorts
of other things that can happen to you
that aren't directed towards you you can
become cynical and you can become bitter
and you can become cruel and you can
become narcissistic and deceitful and
arrogant and and it's like everything's
for you and then you're out for Revenge
that's a nice one I don't know against
who but maybe everyone maybe even
including you because you're not happy
about the rule you've played in
generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still lifes they used to
put a Memento momento Mori often in the
in the still life like a skull somewhere
in the corner or sometimes sometimes in
in a very strange perspective so that
you could only see this skull if you
were standing like right beside the
painting instead of dead on but the idea
was to always remember you know that
everything that exists is Tainted or
touched with the with the with the with
it with the taint of mortality and you
know that's rough but there's some
useful things in it it keeps you awake
and it keeps you focused if you're
careful but it also does indicate to you
if you think about it the necessity of
having a meaning in your life because
because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's it's bad enough to have
something bad happen to you and it's
likely that that'll happen but it's even
worse for you to do it to yourself and
to know that you did it that's rough and
it's also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the D default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning part of
the cultural battle that we all find
ourselves enveloped in is partially due
to the claim that there's virtually
nothing other than the lust for power
and you know I would say
fair enough in some limited sense which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because you see that as a Temptation
that might be powerful enough to bend
and distort you as you attempt to make
your way through let's say the halls of
power
well
[Music]
I heard recently from a reliable source
that Putin's conversion to Orthodox
Christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
I would say that
I would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
we're thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
I would say
foreign
from a clinical perspective service to
others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns I and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and I'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish I'm not saying
that at all I'm saying that one of the
way out one of the roots out of
depression appears to be an increase in
service to other people and I think the
reason for that is because we aren't
power mad demons at the core even though
we may be tempted by such things and
that we find the genuine meaning that
offsets genuine suffering in the genuine
service to others and I think it's a big
mistake to be cynical especially
prematurely about such things as
political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say they're
adversarial and uh and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve
and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere Victory mere
operationalized Victory or instrumental
Victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political Realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often I
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber and that's a
big mistake and you can think about that
more deeply too is that we all have to
put we all need a place to place the
existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history right because even
the grounds we walk on here which this
is a remarkable and wonderful place I
mean English soil is soaked with blood
just like the soil of every place in the
world that's part of the human Heritage
and all of us bear the marks of that
conflict in some sense in our souls
partly because of the possibility for us
to engage in that but also partly
because part of the reason we're here in
all this privilege is because of all
that catastrophe well the best way to
localize that malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing that true source of
malevolence let's say with your mere
political enemies and that isn't to say
that you won't encounter malevolent
Behavior although most of it in the
political sphere as it is everywhere
most of it is more ignorance than
malevolence although willful blindness
certainly plays a large role and so you
need to know what it is that you're
serving and I would say one of the ways
to do that practically are a couple of
ways to do that practically is you need
a good team around you the people you
really trust and who can watch you and
who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing I
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and Power and so if you
know those things if you know you need
to listen you need to get in touch with
the people you're representing as
regularly as you possibly can and mostly
to listen
um I knew a man in Canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success though that he became
the leader of the opposition in Canada
within about 10 years and I asked him
how he did that because it's like well
really how did you do that that's
actually really hard and he said he
would go out from constituency to
constituency and make his stump speeches
but what he really liked was the Q and
A's because people would tell him what
their problems were then he knew what
the problems were and out of the
dialogue would also emerge the answers
that the audience found compelling and
so not only would they tell him what the
problems were but they would tell him
the answers they would like to have it
have have what instituted to solve those
problems and it's the same thing that
comedians do when they when they finast
finesse their acts in front of live
audiences before they practice them in
front of a large audience they lit they
tell jokes and the audience see their
laughs or they don't if they laugh then
you keep that joke and if they don't you
throw it out and soon you're just as
funny as the audience can possibly
manage and it's the same thing you can
also do that in a dark manner by the way
which is what Hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for response and collect those and
so then you become the embodiment of The
Shadow of Your people so I would
recommend that you probably don't do
that you speak about the concept of the
Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's
there's I would say what we mean by soul
is something like animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say what a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read and all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest station and
if you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the father person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net to
score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated the soul is participating
in that in the fullest extent and you
know you can say well there's no use for
the religious there's no necessary use
for the religious terminologies like
well until you come up with a better
word there's plenty of use for it
because it's a very complex and deep
phenomena and to you know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if they're free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth human
consciousness is that faculty that
confronts potential itself I think
there's good neurological evidence for
this by the way for those of you who are
scientifically minded because uh we
build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is further
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and and really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worth and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good you know
there's a gospel saying which is of
course impossible to comprehend or
believe knock in the door will open
asking you will receive seek and you
will find and people think well no way
the world's not constituted like that
it's like it goes back to the idea of
aim
if you don't aim at it you're not going
to hit it and you know it might also go
back to a question about what do you
mean by ask and what do you mean by want
because it isn't just some casual
request you know you're praying to God I
wish you know I wish I could find my
wallet or something like that as if he's
the Casual granter of Magical Wishes
like like the like a fairy with a magic
wand you know it's not that asking means
something like this I am willing to give
up everything
that I'm doing wrong
so that I can put things right if I
could know what right was and that's a
non you're on your knees when you say
that man and maybe if you're on your
knees you get the answer
and so that's worth thinking about so
you know if you knock and you wanted to
walk through it you asked and you wanted
to learn
you know and you saw it because you
wanted to find maybe you would receive
and be answered and
find
but not without aim if you don't have
some notion of the Divine then you'll
believe any damn thing yeah yeah right I
think that's right and that's what the
kids are doing yeah well I mean
dostoevsky's comment on that was if
there's no God everything is permitted
you know and he did a lovely job of
analyzing that in well in crime and
punishment and the brothers karamazov
and I think it's true I think you'll if
you believe nothing you'll fall for
anything and I really do believe that's
the case and you know you might say well
what what do you mean
you mentioned earlier that people like
to ask me if I believe in God and I
always think well
who are you to be asking that question
first of all you have some notion of
what you mean by believe that you think
is just accurate because you know what
believe means and so you have a a priori
theory about belief and now you're
asking me if my belief in God fits into
your a priority Theory it's how about we
start by questioning your a priority
theory of belief because I don't even
know what you mean by believe and
neither do you especially when we're
asking a question not
profound because it you know
do you believe in God there's two
Mysteries there well three you believe
God all three of those are subject to
um question
I think people act out what they believe
and so when people ask me if I believe
in God I say generally that I act as if
God exists or I try to act as if God
exists and they're not very happy about
that because they want me to abide by
the rules of the implicit rules of their
question which is no
do you believe in the religious view as
a pseudo-scientific description of the
structure of reality it's like well
I don't even know how to answer that
question because it's so badly
formulated I can't get a handle on it
um
do you believe that there's something
divine
well let's try to Define divine here we
can do that for for a moment most of us
have some sense that literary stories
differ in their depth that's that I
don't think that's an unwarranted
proposition some stories are shallow and
some stories are deep some stories are
ephemeral in some move you deeply
whatever that means it's a metaphor but
we understand what it means
imagine there are layers of literary
depth and one way of conceptualizing the
layers of literary depth is that the
deeper an idea is the more idea other
ideas depend on it
right and so you have fundamental ideas
that are fundamental because if you
shake that idea you shake all the ideas
that are dependent on them and then I
would say well the realm of the Divine
is the realm of the most fundamental
ideas and you don't get to believe in
that or not because the alternative is
to say well all ideas are equal in value
it's like okay well try acting then
and you can't because you can't act
unless you prioritize your beliefs and
if you prioritize them you arrange them
into a hierarchy and if you arrange them
into a hierarchy you accept the notion
of depth
and so that's a no-go
when we use language of the Divine we're
talking about the deepest ideas
and so I believe that
the notion that each individual
is characterized by a Consciousness that
transforms The Horizon of the future
into the present that's a Divine idea
it's so deep and our cultures
necessarily I think functional cultures
are necessarily predicated on that idea
so I don't just think it's a western
idea I don't think you can have a
functional culture that in some sense
doesn't instantiate that idea because
you interfere with the mechanism of
adaptation Itself by not allowing it
free expression
you know and you can be like my prime
minister and you can say well I really
admire the Chinese Communist party
because when it comes to environmental
issues they get things done and I think
I I couldn't begin to tell you how many
things are wrong with that statement
that would take like 15 years to tell
you why your uh an inexcusably
narcissistic idiot but we can start like
simply if you know what you're doing and
you have power if you know what you're
doing maybe you can be more efficient
in your exercise of in your control over
movement towards that goal let's just
assume for a minute that you do know
what you're doing well maybe if you have
power then you're efficient fair enough
man
what about when you don't know what
you're doing
how about then where do you turn because
what that means is your ideology failed
you and do you have a mechanism for
for operating when you don't know what
you're doing well no because we always
know what we're doing because we're
totalitarian and we have a complete
theory of everything and don't say
anything to the contrary or else we've
got it all wrapped up yeah except when
you don't
and so what do we do in free societies
when we don't know what we're doing well
we let people talk
and out of that Babble out of that noise
and American culture is particularly
remarkable in this regard you have this
immense diversity of opinions most of
which are completely useless and some of
which are absolutely Redemptive and one
of the things that's so remarkable as a
Canadian observing your culture in
particular is that you know you guys
Veer off in weird directions fairly
frequently and things look pretty
unstable and then there's some glimmer
of hope somewhere that bursts forward in
in a whole new mode of adaptation and
Away you go again and that just happens
over and over and over and that's a
consequence of real diversity of real
diversity and it's definitely a
consequence of like freedom of
Association and freedom of speech
because it enables all that you're at a
crossroads right here entering a new
phase of your life you can
you're someone different than you were
four years ago
and hopefully someone better
likely someone better
and you have another opportunity now to
be the next iteration of yourself
that you can be
at a Crossroads you know
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go One Direction or another
and there's an old blues idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads I
always wondered why that was I thought
it through it's a really compelling
idea you know it's a it's an image that
has a good narrative fit and it sticks
in your memory once you hear it why do
you meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight maybe that's when you let
examine your conscience
or it examines you
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally
because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
and I think this is actually true of
every choice we ever make but it's more
evident when the choice is more
weighty let's say
as the choices that lay themselves out
now in front of you are waiting you aim
up or down
and there is always an agent of
Temptation at every choice Point
enticing you
to aim down
and I thought a lot about what aiming
down means and so all
run through that for a bit the spirit of
Temptation manifests itself for example
in the story of Cain and Abel and so
Cain Falls prey to Temptation and God
bluntly informs him
when he complains about his fate that
the Temptation was freely Chosen and
that he could have done differently and
better and Cain becomes this is in the
aftermath of the improper
sacrifices that he makes
the sacrifices that he makes that are
not everything they could be
they're not in the service of the
highest good
that are deceptive and arrogant
simultaneously because when we make
improper sacrifices we believe in the
deepest part of ourselves that we've
pulled one over God
and Isis suggests that that's a
Temptation you might want to avoid that
presumption
and then you might say well if you're
tempted to aim down
you're tempted to make improper
sacrifices you're tempted to arrogantly
presume that you are going to get away
from it with it that you're not going to
be called on it
what are the pathways down that might
manifest themselves in front of you and
I think the the two stories that follow
the story of Cain and Abel
detail that
so after Cain and Abel Comes The Flood
and that's no accident The Narrative
placement of those stories is definitely
no accidents it's unbelievably
sophisticated from a literary
perspective a philosophical perspective
theological perspective
existential perspective one form of
Temptation is
the nihilistic chaos that's symbolically
represented by the flood right it's the
proliferation of sins
and sin is a word
both its Greek and its Hebrew derivation
are related to archery so the Greek
derivation I hope I haven't got this
wrong because I know there are Greek
scholars in this audience so um the the
word is derived from the Greek word
hamartia which means to miss the mark
and it's an archery term it's lovely I
it's a lovely notion to know that
because to sin therefore means to miss
the target which implies that it has
something to do with aim or the lack
thereof I love that I think it's so apt
and the derivation of the word sin from
the Hebrew Source actually relies on the
same imagery and so to sin is to aim
wrong or to miss the mark and there's a
variety of ways you can miss the mark
right don't aim at all that's a good one
assume there is no such thing as aim
assume all aims are equal
well you sin you missed the mark what
can happen well one way is you can
descent into a kind of nihilistic
hopelessness and that's not you can
understand that you know you meet people
in life whose lives have been so hard
you know you hear their stories they've
suffered so much and they're bitter and
they're hurt and they're resentful and
you think oh my God it's no wonder
you're bitter and hurt resentful I mean
look what you've gone through and but
you also notice that their bitterness
and their resentment and their
hopelessness and their chaos and their
anxiety it's not helping
right it's worsening the problem it's
not making it better and I'm not saying
that people can always resist that
but I I have certainly seen that it's
not helpful but I've also met other
people you know who have had stories
equally catastrophic sometimes more
catastrophic sometimes so catastrophic
you can't even believe that they
survived who are not embittered or made
residential by those experiences and who
continue to aim up and so that makes a
mockery of the of the of a kind of
casual determinism right is that you end
up chaotic nihilistic hopeless anxious
Etc
merely as a consequence of the
unbearable tragedy of your life because
if that was the case then everyone who
had a series of unbearable tragedies
which by the way will be almost all of
us in one way or another at one time or
another would end up
in that catastrophic chaos that that
once
that if manifested broadly enough in a
society produces a flood of
that ends everything and that's well
that's the story of Noah in large part
and Noah you know he's wise in his
Generations was a lovely phrase because
it means for his time and place he was a
good man and that's that's a lens
through which history might well be
viewed you know we're very presumptuous
as moderns we look back and we think
well you know this person who did all
these remarkable things said these
things that we now regard as
inappropriate and therefore can be
dispensed with it's like well what makes
you think that you're above that
criticism 100 years from now that you
know the best you can do is to be as
good as you can in your time and place
and if you could manage that well good
for you if you can transcend that well
then maybe you're some sort of Saint and
you're probably not so aiming at just
the first is not such a bad upper aim
first of all I do believe that I don't
think science is possible outside of an
encompassing judeo-christian ethic
so for example I don't think you can be
a scientist without believing as an
axiom of faith that truth will set you
free or that will set us free so we
don't know the conditions under which
science is possible you know and we tend
to overestimate its
epistemological potency it's only been
around I mean you can stretch it back to
the Greeks if you're inclined but in a
formal sense it's only been around for
about five centuries and it's only
thrived for a very short period of time
and it's perfectly reasonable to assume
that there were particular preconditions
that made its rise and descendancy
possible it is a historical phenomenon
yes it happened at a specific moment in
time right and for and at least
yeah and I think one of the conditions
well there's a bunch of them one is for
example there there's an intense
insistence in the Christian tradition
that the mind of God in some sense is
knowable yes so we could say well the
structure of the cosmos and you have to
believe that that's the case before
you're going to embark on a scientific
Endeavor you have to believe that
there's some relationship between logos
logic let's say but logos is a much
broader concept than logic that's for
sure you have to believe that there's
some relationship between that and the
structure of the cosmos you have to
believe that the pursuit of truth is in
itself an ethical good because why would
you otherwise bother you have to believe
that there is such a thing as an ethical
good and those aren't scientific those
are not scientific questions which is
why I think the arguments of people like
Hitchens are weak it's like yeah
Hitchens Dawkins people like that they
have a metaphysic which they don't know
and they assume that metaphysic is
self-evidence like well sorry guys it's
actually not self-evident and they
assume that it can be derived from the
observations of empirical reality and
the answer to that is
no there's going to be axioms of your
perceptual system that aren't derivable
from the contents of your perceptual
system and you might think well that's
not very scientific and I would say well
take it up with Roger Penrose and see
what he thinks
because I just talked to him for like
three hours about partly about this
topic about say the role of
Consciousness and and the structure of
Consciousness and it's by no means
obvious that the materialist
reductionists have the correct
theory about the nature of Consciousness
and not surprisingly it's like we we
don't understand the relationship
between Consciousness and being at all
and so they're you know these are hard
hard questions well they're the hardest
the hard question for Consciousness
researchers is uh why is there
Consciousness rather than why aren't we
just unconscious mechanisms acting
deterministically they call that the
hard question I don't think that is the
hard question I think the hard question
is what's the relationship between
Consciousness and being itself and
because I don't I can't understand what
it means for something to be in the
absence of some awareness of that being
so when we say being there's an
awareness component implicit in the in
the idea of being itself Consciousness
is integrally tied up with being in some
mysterious Manner and so
and I also don't believe that the the
most sophisticated scientists are by
necessity reductionist materialists like
get as far as you can with that no
problem it's it's Occam's razor clear if
you can reduce and account
deterministically no problem but don't
be thinking that accounts for everything
because I don't think there's any
evidence that it does so imagine that
you're in Amsterdam during World War II
and the Nazis are everywhere and you
have a Jewish Family in the attic and
you're up there with the baby and
there's 25 Nazi officers on the ground
floor the baby starts to cry
do you smother the baby you save all the
people upstairs and Claire who is a
mother of a very young child at that
time said her response was don't ask me
such stupid questions which I think is
actually the right response and it's
more embodied response right and you you
can trap your philosophical cognition
into weird corners but that doesn't mean
that your fundamental intuitions are
affordable this is right with this nosik
thing it's it's like well if you could
not have a body yeah you know you're
grounded out in the world that's that's
the rejection of Derek parfitt right so
Derek parfitt's entire moral theory is
the trolley problems and you can decide
how morality is constructed based on
trolley problems and people like well
that's not really how morality is
constructed it's not all based on edge
cases not really how it's constructed at
all it has to be embodied for example
and that's a crucial issue you know and
so the the notion that a set of semantic
philosophical propositions even
coherently organized constitutes the
ethical world and that ethics is top
down from magic space into your body
space that's there's some truth in that
because there's feedback loops right we
think about ethics and we can we can
move around the edges of ethics and so
forth but it's within a game that's
already established and that game is
actually established through embodied
negotiation first so when you see Moses
leading his people through the desert
they're all fighting and scrapping away
right and then he sits as judge of them
for a very long period of time it's
months or years even so much that his
father-in-law says you have to stop
doing this because it's exhausting you
right it's after that he receives the
revelations from on high and so my sense
of that psychologically is it's a story
about the fact that morality is encoded
in our behavior in a deep level and so
deep we actually don't understand the
morality but then now and then we get an
imaginative insight into the moral
pattern and then we get a semantic
representation of the imaginative
insight and that's this Revelation it's
like here's a moral rule it's like
wolves suddenly becoming semantically
conscious of the
Authority relationships in their pack oh
that's really good I like that a lot
yeah that's quite good like 20 years ago
put a lot of effort into that yeah no
there's a there's a there's a big kind
of Rich debate in Jewish philosophy over
whether Moses is right to listen to
Jethro so Jethro comes and says you need
to you need to devolve authority to
lower levels you need the the prince you
need the judges of the tens and then the
judges the hundreds yeah yeah which is a
lovely way of thinking about it too
because it parse out I thought that's
what should have happened in Iraq right
kill the Tyranny well what do you do you
have to establish a hierarchical local
Authority exactly so centralized control
doesn't work but one of the big
questions is whether in doing that is
Moses setting the stage for all of the
chaos that follows because once you give
up the authority that he has the direct
Authority and you have now layers of of
authority below him how much Authority
can you devolve to layers below you
without giving up the the prime
Authority at the top right that is like
one of the Cardinal questions of life
isn't it you know if you have a family
you want to devolve a Authority and
facilitate autonomy and the question is
how much can you do that without without
generating disunity and I would say it
depends on the value of the goal that
unites you and and then that brings up
another question and this is a question
I would say for the moral relativists
um I was talking to Rupert sheldrake in
in Cambridge he has lots of wild ideas
but
I was conducting a seminar there
on the nature of the uniting ideal so it
was imitation of the Divine ideal say
you need a higher order aim to unite
subordinate drives right so the question
then is what becomes the highest order
epic great it's like the pyramid with a
gold cap on the top or the Washington
Monument with a pyramid on top of it
with this aluminum cap on something's at
the top and the thing that's at the top
is actually qualitatively distinctive
from all the things that are subordinate
to it so the question is what's that
highest order uniting principle and
well one answer to that that the three
religions that are based on books have
proposed is it has something to do with
the authority of the word and
Christianity that's developed into the
notion of the Divine word and you see
that saturating Judaism as well and
that's at least in part because the
thing that has to be superordinate is
freedom of
it's not freedom of fight exactly it's
more like freedom of Consciousness
because logos isn't thought it's not
logic either it's much broader than that
it's more like Consciousness itself and
the reason I think that's true
technically is because we imagine that
Consciousness and attention are in some
sense isomorphic right I mean when we
pay attention to something we become
conscious of it okay Consciousness
Consciousness is the mechanism that
generates proximal Solutions and
dissolves and regenerates them and so
all the proximal Solutions have to be
made subordinate to respect for the
process that generates old okay yeah
yeah exactly well I think it's a
cardinal presupposition of psychotherapy
because what you do in Psychotherapy is
you allow people maximal freedom of
expression right you don't impose your
views on them even you the freudians use
free association say whatever comes into
your mind and it turns out that that
process of
untrammeled expression in good faith is
actually Curative it actually makes
people better it leads them to what
they're afraid of that that's one of the
consequences of free speech right
because you sort of you tend to
circulate around what bothers you and
what disturbs you and so untrammeled
freedom of expression will lead you to
the source of your fears and then you
can confront those fears and then in
confronting them you can get more
courageous that's all part of that the
other thing that that ideology does and
the the radical leftists are all also
very good at this is that
it provides you with a local a
convenient Locale for the for the uh
existence of evil
and so if you reflexively identify the
patriarchy with evil
well first of all that's a powerful idea
it it independent of its broad Merit
it's a it's true
now it's not the only truth and it's not
the complete truth but it's true the
reason it's true is because every
hierarchical system hierarchical system
degenerates tends to degenerate in the
direction of power and all hierarchical
systems are less than they could be and
that's partly because of the possibility
that power and deceit will corrupt them
but also partly because we're willfully
blind and deceitful in our own personal
lives and so when you tell young people
that
the cause of the trouble they see around
them in the world and maybe even the
disquiet in their own heart is the
malevolent inadequacy of their society
that Rings true and they don't hear the
rest of the story you know and it's the
rest of the story that I've been trying
to tell they don't hear this story that
yeah don't forget about the evil and
Corruption that exists in your own heart
and don't forget about the fact that
nature
in this wondrous goddess as portrayed by
the anti-human environmentalists and I
by that I don't mean all
environmentalists by the way
that wonderful goddess nature is also
trying to
make you ill and kill you at all times
and so but the story that corruption
exists in hierarchical structure
and that that's a consequence of
malevolence the malevolent use of power
and deceit that's true
so it's very motivating especially if
you're young and you're looking for an
invention now it's also too convenient
which is one of its tremendous dangers
Because unless you're taught to look
within and identify the malevolence
there as the primary moral obligation
then you now have an excuse and a moral
justification to take out all of your
negative emotion your hostility your
resentment everything about you that's
unexamined on the Demonic Enemy and of
course that's that that degenerates with
extraordinary rapidity as we as we've
seen over and over and over
so it's up to the it's up to the
centrists on both sides to to deal with
this I've been talking to a lot of The
Optimist rationalist Types on my podcast
Matt Ridley and Bjorn lomberg and well
and height and and Pinker more more
distantly but more recently uh Bloomberg
and and Ridley and and uh Marion tupi
who who's written a lovely book on uh
human progress uh 10 things everyone
needs to know about human progress it's
something like that huh anyways
one of the things we discussed
consistently was the difficulty in
promoting the message that all three of
these men are very aware of which is
that from a material perspective in
terms of absolute privation
worldwide
humanity is way better off on virtually
every Dimension you could possibly
measure than ever and and most of that
Improvement has occurred in the last 40
years and it's been revolutionary in its
speed and no one knows this
and so it's very important to note to
try to think through why that is like
that's such a positive message now I
talked to Russell Brand about this and
I'm bringing him up for a reason he's
he's a lefty by temperament and by heart
and his first objection but he's very
thoughtful and quick his first objection
you know I pointed out all this data
showing that by every possible objective
measure everything is way better than it
was
certainly a hundred years ago but
certainly even 20 years ago even on the
environmental front in the main
and he said well what about disparity of
distribution so there's the problem of
absolute level of wealth let's say now
it's improving but there is still
tremendous disparity and of course that
that is fair enough you could even point
out that the role of the left is to
provide a conscientious voice for
for that's constantly attending to the
fact of continuing disparity regardless
of absolute level of wealth and fair
enough but
but having said all that
it's a great mystery that incremental
optimism is not sufficiently motivating
and you can't just wish human nature is
going to change it's not going to change
we got to tell a better story and I also
think that's why I'm a Target
I think is because I am actually trying
to tell a better story and I'm actually
having some success with it I think
faith is a form of courage
you know if you're hurt by life and you
will be
it's understandable that you might react
in a nihilistic and hopeless fashion and
become anxious and depressed and cynical
and bitter and all of that
uh that's a bad pathway
and I think part of what helps you
through that is Faith and and part of
that faith is that it's incumbent upon
you and actually in your best interest
and everyone else is to maintain faith
in the fundamental goodness of existence
including your own despite the evidence
to the contrary
right because you can draw conclusions
from suffering in two ways right one is
that you have a duty and perhaps the
capability to transcend the suffering is
still serve the good or you can derive
the conclusion that life is so
unbearable that it would be best
terminated which is the conclusion that
girth is Mephistopheles derives for
example in Faust he says well the world
is Rife with suffering and it's so
unbearable that Consciousness itself all
being should cease to exist that would
be better nothing is better than
something if something is right with
suffering and you can derive that
conclusion and you'll be driven to it in
some
of the farther reaches of your life when
terrible things happen to you but I
would say
faith is the courage to not take that
path despite the evidence that that
might be justified
and so I think it is a form of courage
in the highest sense and I also think it
is a redeeming form of courage one of
the things I told my daughter who was
very very ill for a very long period of
time and in tremendous pain and
suffering the high probability of
continued slow painful inevitable
degeneration was
do not let your illness do not take
advantage of your illness as an excuse
and I told her that when she was in
grade two you know it's no joke to tell
someone that because I knew she'd had
every reason to be embittered but I also
knew that if she was
in combination with realness the two
things might be worse than fatal and you
know if you don't think there are things
that are worse than fatal you have not
suffered because there are things that
are much worse than fatal and that's
certainly not something you want to do
near a child to so one of the things
I've been talking to my audiences about
is the relationship between
responsibility and meaning which is what
would you say it's a it's a constant
refrain in the book it's one of its
underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the Baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons but
you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the Instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear conscience is different than
happiness that's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've Justified you've
Justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
are you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or or yeah or or the things
that you've that you've let go that you
should have capitalized on and all of
that and so if you think about the times
when you're at peace with yourself with
regards to how you're conducting
yourself in the world it's almost always
conditions under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt I think that you can
experience perhaps is the sure knowledge
that you're not even taking care of
yourself so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people because
that's pretty pathetic and I unless
you're Psychopathic and you know and
you're living a parasitical life and
that that characterizes a very small
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
only are you not taking care of yourself
let's say so someone else has to but
you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that I came
about the idea is that I'm going to
relate to you
by a variety of roots
oh
conducting investigations in a variety
of disciplines
uh scientific disciplines to the degree
I was capable of doing that and
inquiries into
literary reality
because literature has its reality I
mean not only its existence as
literature which is obviously real but
in what it portrays which is very
interesting because we all know that
literary portrayals are fictional and we
all know that fiction isn't true
but we all know that literature is true
and deep literature is particularly true
and so that's seems to pose somewhat of
a problem
um
I came to the ideas that I'm discussing
too because I noted the emergence of a
problem across multiple disciplines and
it's a very serious problem in fact I
would say it's a problem so serious that
it took
three and a half billion years of
evolution to solve
um
and that would be the problem of
perception
you know the world is given to us in our
perceptions and we confuse the world
that we perceive with the actual world
and
we have to because
we're stuck with
our limited and ignorant perceptions and
so
it's necessarily the case that we bump
up hard against the underlying reality
that those perceptions are trying to
represent
I read a paper in the MIT Handbook of
cognitive science a while back it wasn't
the first place I'd encountered this
idea but it was stated pretty briefly
and so it's a good way of laying out the
problem the problem is really one of
interpretation and it bedeviled
or artificial intelligence researchers
who were attempting to
produce functional robots that could
operate in real world environments and
you'll note we have none of those yet
although we are getting much closer
um it bedeviled cognitive scientists and
and psychophysiologists who are trying
to understand visual perception which
turns out to be complicated Beyond
Comprehension I mean we devote about
half our brain
it's really more than that to just
seeing
and it's interesting to contemplate why
that might be if the world in some sense
is given and composed of
self-evidently apprehensible objects
which it's not
at all
and the problem also emerged in in
literary criticism and interestingly
enough it's emergence there
sparked I would say
the culture war that we're all engaged
in at the moment and so this is not a
trivial problem and
the MIT researchers that I described met
in an Aguilar said
it is possible to categorize a finite
number of objects in an infinite number
of ways
and you think well that doesn't sound
like too serious a problem but it's
actually a really serious problem
because it means that any
snapshot of reality let's say any visual
snapshot of reality certainly any
conceptual snapshot of reality like a
book
is subject to an unending number of
potential interpretations and we could
perhaps quibble about whether that's
actually infinite but I don't think
that's really matters there's all sorts
of mathematical discussions about the
true nature of infinity and
that's the point the point is there are
lots of them way more than you could
ever sort through
and so how how do you do it and how do
you do it in such a mat in a manner that
really makes it simple in some sense
because there's the step and
there it is and I walk down and no
problem except like I said took three
and a half billion years to evolve the
platform that made that perception
possible and so if it took God himself
you know three and a half billion years
to manage it then it's a rather
difficult problem to solve
so I started studying cybernetics
neuropsychology
animal behaviorism
literary Theory psychoanalytic theory
existential philosophy biblical studies
physics to a limited degree evolutionary
biology evolutionary psychology
measurement Theory construct validation
Theory all these different diverse
domains of inquiry
trying to triangulate this problem
although more than triangulate because I
was using more than one reference point
it was a good methodological it's a good
method by which to proceed if you can
find an answer that manifests itself in
multiple historically detached
disciplines simultaneously it's some
evidence that that idea is valid you're
you do that with your senses you have
five senses if all five senses which are
quite qualitatively distinct
point to the same thing then you can be
reasonably but not certainly sure that
it's there
up by reasonably but not certainly I
mean
if that was all there was to specifying
the objects of perception properly we
wouldn't have to talk to each other and
find out what other people think
but we do because even with that
quintangulation let's say
we still Orient ourselves unreliably in
the world what I think is at the core of
the postmodern critique
um I don't think you can look at the
world except through a structure of
value and the the English so you think
well how did the why is literary
criticism so relevant well or become so
relevant and so powerful and I think
well
I believe that we see the world through
a narrative framework
and so that if that's true and we could
talk a little bit about that what I mean
by that I think you need a mechanism to
prioritize your attention
and to because attention is a finite
resource and it's costly so you have to
prioritize it and there's no difference
between prioritizing your attention and
imposing a value structure those are the
same thing and then I think that the
mechanisms that we use to prioritize our
attention are stories and that means
that the people who criticize our
stories actually have way more power
than you think because they're actually
criticizing the mechanism through which
we look at the world and so the
postmodernists would say look you even
look at the scientific world through a
value-laden lens and I think yeah you do
uh they're right but what they're not
right about is that the lens is one of
power and now for someone like Nietzsche
the thing about a word like power is you
can expand the thing the borders of the
word to Encompass virtually any
phenomena you want and so that's why I
tried to Define power as my willingness
to use compulsion on you or other people
because power can be Authority power can
be competence I don't mean any of that I
mean you don't get what you to do what
you want I get to tell you course
exactly and uh and I do think the
Marxist types view the willingness to
use coercion as the driving force of
human history and that's really saying
something because that means it's the
fundamental motivation and uh that's a
very caustic criticism and it's easy to
put people back on their heels about
that you know one of the things you see
about capitalists because I've been
stunned to see the CEOs of major
corporations like roll over in front of
these Dei activists I think well what
the hell is wrong with you people you
know you're not even making use of your
privilege and why are you
um well it's not very powerful if you're
the CEO of a major corporation you can't
even withstand some interns who have Dei
ideology it's like it's doing you a lot
of good and uh
so
and why would you produce a fifth column
within your organization that's
completely opposed to the entire manner
in which you do business and the
capitalist Enterprise as such and one
answer would be well we don't think much
about ideas it's like well maybe you
should and and you know you can be
cynical about it and say well it's just
a gloss to keep the capitalist
Enterprise going while appearing to to
meet you know the new demands of of
ethical re of the new ethical reality
which I think is a bad argument too but
more importantly it's that people are
guilty
and the the radicals who accuse us all
historically and as individuals of being
motivated by nothing but the desire for
power
strike a chord especially in people who
are conscientious you know because if
you're a conscientious person and
someone comes to you and says like a
little mob of 30 people who says you
know you could be a little more careful
in what you say and do on the racist
front and the sexist front Etc
you're likely to think well
I'm not perfect I probably could be a
little more careful and it's no doubt
that people have been oppressed in the
past and it's also no doubt that in some
sense I'm the undeserving beneficiary of
historical atrocity and so you know
maybe I should look to myself and
that's weaponization of guilt and it's
very effective and it's not surprising
but it's not helpful so you know so so
there's a resentment that drives this
like a corrosive resentment that's able
to weaponize guilt and it's very
difficult for people to withstand it
make friends with people who want the
best for you and that's a meditation on
my own childhood and Adolescence to some
degree I had friends who wanted the best
for me and friends who didn't and you
know they were friends who
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up then they're
generally not that happy about it you
know they try to top your accomplishment
with one of their own hypothetical or
real or put down what you're doing or
offer you a cigarette if you're trying
to quit and you've kind of done that
successfully or a drink if you've been
drinking too much and are trying to stop
being an alcoholic you know or or yeah
they're cynical and bitter and and
devoted towards no good and sometimes
that's family members too and sometimes
it's even part of you you know but this
chapter is a injunction to people is
like
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself you have an
ethical responsibility to surround
yourself with people who have the
courage and and faith and wisdom to wish
you well when you've done something good
and to stop you when you're doing
something destructive and if your
friends aren't like that then they're
not your friends
and maintaining your friendships with
them might not even be in their interest
and so it's a tricky argument to make
because I'm not saying you know whenever
anyone's in trouble you should you know
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks that's that's not
the idea
the idea is that but I had a couple of
rules I didn't write about one was be
careful uh be careful about whom you
share good news with and another was be
careful about whom you share bad news
with and everyone those rules ring in
people's minds quite quickly a friend is
someone you can share good news with you
know you go to them and you say hey look
this good thing happened to me and they
say look I'm so happy that that happened
to you like way to be and they don't
think God damn it why didn't that happen
to me and like you know you didn't
deserve it here's a bunch of reasons
you're stupid and why it won't work it's
like that's not helpful and so I would
say like if people are
you know what the other thing people are
doing if they're trying to drag you down
let's say is they're trying to see if
you'll put up with it because they have
this idea that maybe life isn't worth
living and things aren't good and then
if they can be smirched let's say to use
an archaic term something that's
pristine and good then they demonstrate
to themselves that there is no true
ideal and that there's no necessary
reason to be responsible and to strive
forward and so they use you which is a
test case you know I'll just push you
down into the low Lobster bin and see
how you respond and if you put up with
it then yeah my cynicism is fully
Justified because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Simon Sonic check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there's a great story of two
Lumberjacks where every morning they
start chopping wood at the same time and
every day they stop chopping wood at the
same time and every day one of The
Lumberjacks disappears for about an hour
in the middle of the day and every day
he chops more wood than the other guy
and this goes on for months